[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
yes sir
yes sir
realm what it do what's going on
talk to me what is happening let's see
who's out there what's going on kevin
list what's going on sick slayer what's
up 4k
120 dolby vision
villa what's going on andrew the diva
yes i think so
mr joanna dark what's going on what's
going on let me know all my levels of
sound christopher what's up hustler
motivate what's up
lord metroid what's going on talk to me
how's my level sounding are we crispy
are we clear how we doing
atomic sand that's what's up
no doubt no doubt what's going on happy
halloween for sure
your name brother that's on 1977. what's
going on ashley what's going on talk to
me peter mcdonald you ought to day off
with a new job let's go you know what
i'm saying
six level listen to your guests for a
while 20 years being so yeah yeah it's
gonna be real thank you metroid thank
you sick just wanna make sure the levels
is good spotlight what's going oh that's
mr wolfe what's up
oh yeah christopher you know you know
you in trouble
i see you trying to defend yourself
early you know what king is about to do
oh shout out to well shout out to you
for being here man much love for all
it's all jokes you know that razor sharp
what's up
oh what's going on what's going on so we
got the legend the legendary
daddy penguin 20 years in a game
should be a special one y'all should be
a special one very excited to talk to
him you know and um it's gonna be fun
y'all addicts in the building stepped
away
x-coyote said it's early yeah it's the
lord's day you already know we already
know
oh hustle got his back
let's see let's see you know what i'm
saying that boy that boy king is loose
it's hard to stop him right now when
he's right
i told y'all like you don't want that
man to be right
he's right
you gonna hear it
alex says stand down
so now so let me go get the legendary
gamer tag radio danny playing in here
soon
you already know king gonna come through
the legendary the intros that he brings
and of course solve lord smold himself
sorry gunner what's up
so yo we'll be back and i will see y'all
in a minute
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on the song with me that's
understandable i kill a beat and they
want to compare me to freddie and jason
i'd rather be hannibal they'd be like
why use a video game just be original
y'all so dramatical i know it's random
but i'm addicted to flipping the sample
and making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to started regardless
back when you was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
look i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled to be your dog thing very loyal
but i ain't gonna hold you i ain't here
to boy you you ain't gotta say it i'm
embarrassed for you i always been a nerd
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
[Music]
which flies
[Music]
imma just chill and watch them many
snacks in the attic i wanted to chill
with the pack and be like a young wolf
but then they would mistake me for
addict if i can imagine it's cool to
give you some advice and invite your
girl to your squadron cause if you don't
give her that option you're gonna be
single player like siren you're gonna
get tossed in the bushes by king david
royalty not a pretender detrimental to
an elemental what's an avatar to a knee
bender i gotta be meto i know it's my
destiny words incognito who cares if you
fly if you steal a mosquito you swear
you ain't something but really be stevo
you like to collect stuff and that's
cool but i got bad news even if you
really was that you can't even still be
the king of the statues since the
juvenile i've been cursed with a curse
to be musical and if you hate it we'll
meet in the crucible wasn't it nothing
it's cool and it's beautiful we let you
know that your dreams are pursuable
whatever you want to do then it's doable
if you got work on a sunday and suitable
cause you can listen to this in your
cubicle on the lord's day
if you got work on a sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on a lord's day
[Music]
all right all right
bikes are hot
here you hear ye and we are live
welcome we're saying that for now on
mics are hot yeah they hot cause you got
a cat big you'll get caught out of
pocket
and we are live welcome to the iron laws
podcast llc and also live on
lordsofgaming.net
episode number
231 it's another glorious sunday we're
back at the round table on the lord's
date i'm extremely excited about our
special guest and we've got close to 20
years of podcasting
halo infinite campaign the playstation
pc brand and xbox game studios future to
discuss so we gonna get right into it
i want to introduce a lord who is truly
a humble legend within the realm of
podcasting and multimedia
not only has this law provided
tremendous opportunity for others but
approximately 20 years ago laid the
foundation for many content creators
with a single
cassette excuse me game attack and a
dream
introducing
the founder and host of the iconic gamer
tag radio and games editorial for x-play
and the legendary g4 tv network
the podfather of gaming
massive keynote speaker and legendary
hall of fame podcasting inductee
live from l.a by way of miami in new
york and making his debut into the realm
of the lords
mommy
lord godfrey aka danny pena how we doing
sir wow that was the best introduction
ever
i love it let's go brother long time
long time coming man we've been trying
to do this for a while man so i'm glad
i'm here man so thank you for
for inviting me bro long overdue man
your lord in your realm an absolute
pleasure we had to roll out the red
carpet show that respect for the pod
father in the building dr stand up how
you doing man which was obviously got a
lot to get into what's going on yeah
yeah what you've been playing as well
what games have you been playing um
honestly i've been playing a lot of
gardeners in the galaxy i was not hyped
for that game at all like when i first
got to see it but man that's one of the
biggest surprises for me man i love it i
heard so much is huge for a lot of
people a lot of people
didn't know that it was going to be what
it is
no it's good it's good honestly like
it's uh it's a definitely must must have
in my opinion for this year like it's so
good really good great story great great
story champion the fact that you're from
the dominican republic i just got to let
you know she keeps tweeting me right now
dr and the builders i see the plot but i
see the flag
shout out to all my dominicans uh out
there man uh
nah nah so i've been playing that a lot
i've been playing a lot of the you know
still
switch oled
you know and there's other stuff i can't
talk about but uh right exclusively
but those those are like the top top
kingston right now i know so righteous
republic i've been trying
right that's
yeah a lot of people love it they love
it man we got a lot to get into so
before we do all that you know we got
the four horsemen of gaming those lords
original realm of the round table what's
up logic what's up here at the round
table a little bit of time sensitive
because we got to respect the hour and a
half by nine minutes
yo how you doing like that how you doing
like
i like that i like that people doing the
intros i don't say nothing
but anyway
[Laughter]
lord of his own world and the how of the
young wolf my man lord addict how we
doing sir
doing pretty good man uh first thing i
want to say is rise republic actually
look it's nothing that like
that would be like crazy crazy to play
for like long's amount of time but i
can't i can't help with the like smile
when i play that game like it's crazy
like it's like ubisoft was like make a
game that you could do anything you
could think of you can literally take
like a jet pack as high as you want to
and then switch to a bicycle would just
fall
wow that's crazy yeah you could switch
you could switch stuff in the middle of
doing anything like you could be using a
glider and switch to a uh some skis at
the last minute like like it's it's a
fun game it's really unique uh you know
playing other games i can't talk about i
saw you streaming that what was that
that joint that looked like eventually
like almost like minecraft graphics with
echo echo generally yeah i saw you
streaming that i look crazy i beat it i
beat it last night it was it was it was
a good game man i beat that last boss he
was pretty rough
oh he did you dirty he hit you with the
time bro hit you with the battle he hit
you with the top
and of course we have
our most technical gaming lord the solo
gamer who lives for the single player
selfish experience and also the
sastradamus
the lord of clarity and lord patriarch
of the iron bank my man lord solve how
we doing sir i'm doing good man i'm
chilling man you know despite having to
go to work later but i'm awake i'm up
hello bro salute
i've been trucking away at metroid dread
little by little just a little bit every
every day at work because that's the
only thing i kind of play when i'm not
home um and then like danny i got in i
got into a little bit of guards of the
galaxy like maybe 45 minutes
i haven't even had combat yet but
everything that i've seen so far
it is like
it's
to me it like production value is crazy
production value is through the roof
when it comes to
like the the dialogue what you expect
from guardians
is there in in kind of abundance like
that movie feels feel good the movie
feeling the fact that yo i don't know
how much dialogue there is in this game
but there's always banter like literally
anytime you're doing anything walking
around whatever there's banter and the
banter makes sense in the context of
what you're doing so it's it's kind of
crazy like it really feels the beginning
part of this game feels like the
beginning part of an uncharted game
kind of cinematically
just one cinematic third person stuff
that [ __ ] but what and the superhero is
that what you implying song yes and that
you know we heard amy hennig is making
the game i heard it i heard everybody be
that i heard a little dead dead daddy
so that's what i've been doing
big shout out to danny man happy to have
danny here this you know daddy he was
supposed to be
the first member of the eminem club the
mongolian
so we already know we got the incredible
hulk of this aka
yo
you're a savage you didn't even start
the intro aka
the excess gamer
the prophet of xbox swami
king of the statues who demands nothing
less than that premium experience it is
the leader of the fraud alert movement
beloved lord king how we doing sir
dominicans stand up oh
let's go
let's get it i saw the flag i was like
oh
yeah and then when we went live as soon
as we went live my wife texts me
let's go dion stand up
um okay so really quickly um i was
playing chivalry too if y'all can catch
that stream oh my god that was hilarious
y'all that was fun so funny a lot of uh
curses slipped
sure they did sure they did
when it comes to those streams
they don't have the same royalties
yeah you was a little loose off
something yeah i said i said you had to
drink your hand yeah
when it comes to
when it comes to those streams king you
don't have the same rules
i'm going to be loose you're ridiculous
what's going on i was playing back for
blood no doubt um my destiny and um
like it's chivalry okay um i played
little uh stuff that was inside game
pass
but
there's one game i've downloaded what's
called non-guns okay what's that guys
it's um um a roguelike okay you're in
the rogue lights lately
it's black and white and it's just weird
oh i saw that yeah okay it's the deluxe
edition i downloaded it i played it for
probably 30 minutes and i uninstalled it
oh damn what happened
i i just you can't shoot up
a lot of the enemies is above you so how
do you want you i gotta get a perk they
can get me something to shoot above my
head but
i'm i i don't play roguelikes to feel
like i'm hampered by the controls
i understand so
um when i'm playing these games i'm
playing stuff like neon abyss um and and
other games
this game just felt like it was
hamstringing me for no reason they
saying you're a little low okay
i'm a little low yeah maybe you're a
little too far back because you got to
drink your head that's all continue
now you're gonna bring that closer there
you go yeah they
but that stream of chivalry too that was
in the making for a long time for you
patreon dudes yes and for people to join
the realm uh we wanted to give something
back uh and attic held it all together
shout out to that
young boy
put the crest up for the wolf put the
crest off
crazy no doubt no doubt you already know
and of course we have the gaming ninja
himself the shinobi lord cognito
spreading that realness in the roman iop
not telling what you want to hear but
what you need to hear yo shout out to
defining duke last week with mr maddie
plays man we have good episodes up check
that out it should be up on 399 on the
last media youtube channel you get a
chance and um also if you want to get in
your mail bag for the patreon users you
know they had to ask cog section so it's
like asking me anything people was
coming up with wild questions i was
telling them tekken stories from back in
the day we used to go to 161 bowling
alley and beat on people we used to go
to chinatown fair you know people wanted
to hear the story so it's funny if you
want some fun stories with me check that
out and then of course for your destiny
fix that last word was lit this week
shout out to ebon to shout out to thai
guy travis for ign we had um the
legendary uh proteon from
destinytracker.com so he's getting into
what's going on in the game all that
good stuff so check that out um as far
as being games it's been bro disco
elysium bro i can't stop playing this
game bro
i'm thoroughly addicted he's the worst
detective known to man he's a drunk he's
a fool but it's just he's a horrible
human being yeah he's just a horrible
human being and i just love that his
conscience get in the way of stuff like
since he's such a bad druggie and it's
like when you on the crime scene if
there's alcohol or something like you
know you want to touch
i'm like yo this game is wild bro like
check that out and i just started the
forgotten city started that see what's
going on with that but that's been it
for me i'm sorry if you want to um get
these super chat now before we start the
rules
yeah we would be remiss if we didn't
shout out the new light heavyweight
champion oh
go over to sarah
every man finally got it done yeah yeah
yeah don't know how long he's gonna hold
on to it but i'm glad he got it done um
this man has been been hustling for a
while he was when he came up everybody
thought everybody was terrified of him
except jon jones of course um and john
jones put him in his place but uh
man yeah i'm glad to see him with the
with the gold around his wings at least
jones on the juice
that might have been jon jones before
all of that
you never know you never know these days
won't stop worldwide jimmy
you know what they're walking yes sir
yeah that's a little bit later
hustle and motivate member for 13 months
no doubt lord bronze jim ryan is the
goat wow
let's put the crest in the chat for rrd
welcome lord oh welcome to the round put
the crest over the chat for you brother
salute
then my favorite name
act
black
conflict
conflict x y'all here baby he referred
the struggle salute to him
happy hollow sunday
no doubt sir then we have six slayer ten
dollar super chat been following godfrey
since pso radio indeed 20 years ago
before ipods and podcasting when it was
audio only talked to a real og in this
game
um and then in parenthesis it says
wonder what happened to chip and zack oh
i could talk about that okay we'll get
to it we get to it yeah yeah yeah then
we have chancleta
that's our people
exactly exactly they're way too
enthusiastic
it wasn't inclusive
and i usually get salami and cheese but
today i got oxtail and jerk chicken
because like worldwide jimmy said you're
not enough
[Laughter]
with the 40 rupee super chat which
headphone is lord saab wearing sir i'm
wearing the rig 800's um these are
awesome but they don't exist anymore you
can find them you can find them but yeah
but um uh plantronics doesn't exist as
plantronics anymore they shifted to more
like
more industrial
i got their new product on oh yeah yeah
they they probably down yeah yeah oh
they're polly
now yeah
then we have black
two dollar super chat everybody outside
today i love it
clock my people no doubt no doubt thank
you sir salute what else do we have we
got gerald mack yes
we chat salute the lords happy lords day
thank you my brother likewise
that's it all right cool so you said the
rules of engagement one more one more
kdk two dollar super chat happy sunday
lords very excited for today's show
absolutely all right so you know the
deal okay tell them
rules of engagement ladies and gentlemen
of course we have to respect danny's
time it is super early over on the west
coast and he's going to be joining us
for like an hour and a half maybe yeah
yeah yeah so um let's see how
so um yeah guys for the most part super
chats will be after uh
one more because it just came in yeah
and no love for tostones today that's
right the next game michael palin's
biggest i might go back and ten dollars
super chat godfrey is the og love gtr
i've been listening before they were
just three i had to listen to cognito
introducing oh thank you you know i had
to give him his roses you already know
so let's get into it so now we got to
what the lord's been playing i'm sorry
you biting right i'm buying oh no what's
going on yes
i'm fine now i'm back
i'm back okay
we can't have that we can't not today
all right no no no hold on yeah i'm
getting it am i still buying i just got
a thing with internet connection a
little bit yes oh i never got that joint
from zoom that's crazy so don't do me
like this oh
still good it's all good all right no
doubt
yeah i see where it says unstable yeah
all right are we going to keep going
look at we see what's going on so now
that we got into what the lords have
been playing i want to focus on lord
danny his video game system history his
journey in podcasting over 20 years and
of course what led him to creating the
historic gamertag radio and his latest
endeavors at g4 tv so lord danny let's
start from the very beginning what was
some of the first video game systems you
had and what got you into gaming
well i actually was my grandmother in
1984
she bought three atari 2600s for for me
and my cousins
and at that time i think uh atari was
running out of i think they were like
out of the the business i think or yeah
they were planning to pick up because
they were struggling with a lot of the
the games wasn't selling et came out
that was like a major failure
yeah
and uh and around that time too nintendo
was also coming to the states yes with
her first concert so she bought me that
console
atari 2600 was 50 bucks at that time and
i remember playing it
playing uh the first games for me was uh
defender
there was a couple other ones the bullet
version of pac-man of course yes yes
i mean that's all we had that's all we
had on the 26th we had that like that
like version of mario brothers did you
have that no wait no i have never had
that one
versions of games i don't it's not i
don't know it's not bootleg addict that
they're the actual games
the the console was just really poor
yeah
it's like
they make it like they make these games
like in a couple weeks okay release it
that's it that's how it was back here
and pac-man didn't
respect not jealous the thing is it's
good to talk about those things because
now it's easy to get all these games now
you know back then it was harder we
didn't have that many options you know
yeah it was either you have the cheap
one or the big mainstream one which is
super expensive but yeah us you know us
back then my parents would be like nah
nah i can't we can't this is too much
money i'd rather save that for like for
bills and stuff like that yeah that's
real that's real yeah yeah so katie yes
you started with that 26 what else you
went to from the 26th yeah from there
nintendo and then i went i moved to
dominican republic and my mom surprised
me with the super nintendo just came out
what's the question when you got the
nintendo did you get the one with rob
and everything or did you just get the
basic i got the the one with the package
with mario brothers and dunk oh
my god yes yeah i think that the
majority of people got that one because
it was already cheaper now yes with that
package you know what i'm saying i mean
that orange gun yes yes
well now for me at that at that time was
the gray joint yeah
original so wait there we go help me out
y'all because that's a good question
like there was a distinct what was the
difference between the orange and the
gray distinction on the light gun for
nes okay um
you want to answer that danny i i can't
honestly i can't remember what was it
what the design it was all right so it
was legislation people was cutting the
clothes off and robbing people oh they
was running up
like they cut
listen back in the bronx back in the
days what if uh yeah i do pull that gun
out gray in the middle of the night
can't tell what's happening
that makes sense it's amazing take my
coins
but you know it's crazy not to divert
but it's so funny you say that because
back in at the same time frame we've all
played with transformers and we had
great megatron which was literally
looking wild outside
too yeah yeah at a period of time they
put that orange thing on the front that
all guns at the time had to have some
orange something in the front you
identified them as toys got you got you
fair definitely
okay well i don't remember i even
remember that king with the school and
me
well
that's why you see all movies and tv
shows and spray painting everything
black yeah
but continue daddy now so when i lived
in the american republic uh i always
was into
radio and videos and everything because
i'm always with experiment with my
family's camera and vcrs and all that
right and my dad used to be a dj
absolutely back then too uh used to do a
lot of tons of house parties in the
early days so i will mess with that and
also i'll get my system and i'm like man
i want to start a business out of this
so
in the early days when i used to live in
the american republic i i went up to my
mom and said to her hey mom i want to
open a business it's kind of like an
arcade but i'm going to charge people
per controller okay this is during the
time where it was like street fighter 2
motor combat 2 nba jam super basis
loaded like golden era so
so i did that and i made tons of money
through mercury and nobody was doing
that at that time that's correct and uh
there was people will drive like three
four hours they will go to
my business in in this town called san
francisco macon okay and they'll see
that they were like damn this is pretty
cool so they'll take the idea yeah
i was like in my early teens early times
what you talking about 13 14
13 14 i think
between 13 to 15 like around that time
okay so you was a businessman early on
yes yes yes always
my mom would love to take that risk like
let's do it my dad was more of like
i need to see yeah i don't want to risk
it i don't know i need to see results
you know i mean so that it's always been
like that that's why uh my mom has
always been supportive when it comes to
ideas and everything that yeah yeah so i
did that i was also living in miami and
then i was involved with like
music i was a big-time hip-hop promoter
back in the 90s yeah yeah so i'll
promote all those clubs at south beach
uh downtown miami and even back in the
days in this area called wynwood now
it's like a tourist area but back then i
was like it was loud it was wow
when the cocaine
danny was in uh
miami yeah
florida yes you know what you have to
say about it i had to say it like that i
don't
know
continue
people don't know that these miami vice
and all that stuff this stuff was really
popping off like yeah right it was
really stuff flying in and flying out
and people were doing things and going
out so yeah at this point in time danny
is in a very dangerous territory and he
is a dj
in being a dj in this era well promoter
promoter that was dangerous brother my
my cousin my cousin's he's a dj i i
experimented dj back then too but
uh yeah
yeah but that's how i know like all the
hip-hop heads back then like like i i
used to work with dj khaled back then
when he just moved from miami and you
know into the whole underground scene
too like now you know him as the
mainstream cat but i've known him as
like that's crazy like back when he was
playing like lords on the ground like
wake up
like those underground hip-hop pets from
back then yeah so
yeah yeah so yeah so i was doing that i
worked also like with uh keras one
consoles during this period of time yeah
i know i had my consoles i still have my
super nintendo still
later i got you know playstation one um
i i almost got a sega saturn thank god i
didn't
but thank god you did the right thing
brother you did the right thing look i
had the sega genesis 32x it didn't feel
right i even had the sega channel before
game pass that was you know talk to him
you know a lot of people know about
things right at the sega channel you
didn't get a saturn no i didn't i did it
the games some of the games had
potential
had potential but i felt like they
released it they rushed it and surprised
they weren't okay you know yeah sega
messed up during that time they messed
up
you know what i'm saying but i respect i
respect i respect say the big time right
so what did so wait since you betrayed
sega at that time and you went saturn um
what what did you end up doing during
that 32-bit era that like what what was
the movie
yo playstation right yeah i'm not
honestly i was more i was always a
nintendo man like
the 1064 you know like
yeah i think um
i skipped second saturn
and then the sega dreamcast was coming
up and i just loved the marketing 99
you know yeah and and that was honestly
that was the console
that completely changed my life
completely talk to us so before before i
mentioned about the release of
uh sega dreamcast before that or in 1998
you know the internet wasn't that big
back then so
i i went to visit my friend's house and
we were playing actually resident evil
the first resident evil game for the
playstation and while he was playing i
was using his computer yeah i'm like oh
let me go online you know let me check
chat with the ladies back there
aol chat
it was lit this is the early days
you know while i was there i was like oh
i will go to like a lot of the hip-hop
message boards back then and they were
like oh nas is live on ada hip-hop for
those who don't know
idiot
was part of this network called sudo
and they were the first
video audio uh streaming service back
then oh wow so i was watching it and i
see nas just like nasa is one of my
favorite hippos
so when i'm watching it he's there
freestyling and i'm like
yo so wait you could do a show online
because i used to do a lot of like
pirate radio stations back then with my
cousins and even khaled
when we would go to his uh twitch show
it was an illegal radio station so for
those who don't know pirate stations
those are stations that are not approved
by the fcc yep oh they had that a lot
like in the hood and the blocks
in miami miami was known as the number
one city with the most pirate station so
they had the uh
that's how he started yeah
yeah just to clarify because uh this i
don't have any uh so there were stations
that wasn't on the radio but on the
radio no no it's there were stations
that you could hear it through the radio
but they were not approved like you need
to get a license from the and approved
from the fcc
before you you know like let's say you
have a those like
mainstream
uh stations right now your error right
those are approved at fcc the ones that
i mentioned there were not so the gun
member will go and shut down the
stations all the time
yeah yeah so i always was into radio
like i said my dad was a radio dj in
this so
when i saw that the interview of nas i
was like yo i want to do this and at
that time i was also writing for a
hip-hop newspaper and we tried to do
this yeah and it was so expensive that i
was like there's no way i'm going to do
it so then fast forward the release of
sega dreamcast just said radio was out
like a bunch of those dope
launch lineup brother that launch lineup
for dreamcast so i experiment a little
bit with just a radio i did like my own
radio station kind of uh so what i did i
grabbed one of those free websites
angelfire.com back in the days
and and i'll put my my show there so the
way how i used to upload it and record
it i'll record everything through
cassette and then upload it to a 56k
modem to that website and it would and
it would take forever for hours so if
somebody calls oh you're done with
disconnect yeah i have to i have to
re-upload it oh yeah shout out to the
56k modem salute yeah so that was back
then so then
so then uh
i already got dsl like oh man this is
that's a big dancer now it's a big deal
back then you know so then i got that
and then the release of fantasy star
online came out the part the first first
one for the second dreamcast and i just
loved the community so much that i'm
like yo if i could record a show and
just talk to my community you know i'll
be dope so then i go to this website
called mp2.com and that website was for
music artists okay so let's say you guys
have a
an album there a couple tracks somebody
listen to it you get paid out of that
so i flipped it let's go put my show
there yeah a lot of people were
listening to it and my first check that
i got was 500 back in february of 2001.
that was my first check so i said yo i'm
going to start a business with internet
radio i have to figure out how i could
do this
so i kept on i got you know multiple
checks from the website but then it got
shut down so i have to like
figure it out all over again like yo it
was very very difficult at that time
people had to go to their computer to
listen to it there was no no smartphones
there was no social media there was no
youtube like and let me stop you for a
second because this is historic stuff i
mean you know obviously we're talking
about like the genesis of your you know
podcasting career and obviously you know
this fantasy story pso you know i saw
you put the tape up you know i said that
was that was fire first once it looked
out that was fine you know but like this
internet radio show because technically
there was no resource like there was
nothing
was there anything at the time doing
talking gaming that you remember
or because as far as i just don't
remember you know what i'm saying so i'm
curious to you if there's anything in
the space at all and nothing right at
all it was just i learned everything on
my own like i learned i learned editing
back then when i used to do mixtapes
with my cousin i would be like on my
tape recorder
pause record pause play record like i
was just doing like that we used to do
all kinds of like we'll do like live
mixtapes and then he will mess up i'll
go back rewind the tape okay hold up
press play okay ready record ready three
two one let's go like
that's how i learned back then how to
edit
so i used that from back then
and and took that to the show that i had
at that time uh with pso radio and
that's how i did it man all my
interviews all everything was like that
so i had multiple tape decks
connected to my computer
and i'll record it on cassette and then
play it
and re-record it through a uh software
to convert it into mp3 in real time it
wasn't like how it is now you know
audacity you know like i had none of
that back then i'm saying probably like
again i didn't have the money i couldn't
buy a digital recorder like i dude like
again i feel like if you're a content
creator
use the resource that you have at the
moment don't try to be like
investing so much yeah like getting that
talk expensive equipment you know what
i'm saying because what happened if it
doesn't work out you know what i'm
saying so
for you do work whether you have some
something cheap use free hosting or
whatever for now and and just master
your skills man and that's what helped
me preach i like how you brought that up
because i had someone reach out to me uh
that king directed to me uh by the way
we got to talk about that later
[Laughter]
they they were asking me about artwork
and stuff and i was like look i was like
if you're gonna spend money don't don't
spend on artwork you don't know what
your brand's gonna be in six months from
now you ain't started i was like you're
gonna spend money spend it on better
equipment like at least get a decent mic
i was like before you spend on artwork
you probably should focus on the
technical side more than anything
because like you know
six months from now you decide okay you
know this is working this isn't working
right then you just realize that you
know i wasted all that money on it yeah
because now i gotta now i gotta have new
artwork so yeah and the thing about it
is it's a great lesson because you know
especially with what danny's saying
about you know
just using what you have at first right
because at the end of the day you got to
figure you're still you know honing your
craft sharpening your skills you got to
figure out if you still love it remember
addict like we bought 10 15 episodes in
or no turtle beach xbox we had to figure
out what the format how the floor was
obviously king and soft took it to the
next level but you know it's one of
those things that i think what the
reason why i love what danny said is
that i think some people get too caught
up like yo i gotta have sure i gotta
have this i gotta have that and then
roblox in front of yourself exactly
the biggest thing i would suggest is
because i do feel like now
you probably should invest a little bit
not a whole lot you at least get like a
a um you know a snowball mic like a 60
70 dollar mic because now
sure you don't need stuff like that and
if you're entertaining and you're
energetic you can you can go past
because you can go past you know what
you what uh your threshold but
now since the quality of everything has
increased i do feel like there is oh
yeah
oh yeah i don't know for sure for sure
but you know sometimes sometimes it's
hard sometimes you ain't got that you
know what i'm saying you literally check
but now how like you got to consider
like especially danny daddy's been in
this for like ever like damn near like
well my life spans
at the end of the day
back then
you could jump into the scene and be
really just be fine because it wasn't a
lot of competition back then in a lot of
these different videos but now
you jump into the audio scene everyone
and everyone at least got a yeti you
jump into the podcasting scene the
majority of people you can hear fine i
mean famous luca will
destroy you over audio
but like i said
if you ain't got that bread all that man
like you could aspire
you could say yo would i get the check
yeah but sometimes you got to do what
you got to do until you get the break
okay
i want to match i want to mention this
very quick because
i i learned all this all this one
because
because i went back and also learned a
lot about the history of hip-hop and
also even the the spanish music scene
into american republic like pachata yeah
bachata at back in the early days
it was known as like oh no that's for
like poor people
because the reason was merengue was like
the mainstream
music scene right like it was huge back
then right and the reason is everybody
had their instruments it was like the
big big thing right bachata people
created this from like the hood right
yeah they didn't have the money
to
buy all those instruments so they had to
ha they had to play music with whatever
instruments they had at the moment and
look back then
nobody the rich folks didn't respect
that genre and look now mainstream and
everything same thing with hip-hop
hip-hop hip-hop back in the days in the
late 70s and 80s
you know all everybody was is all about
disco whatever is hot
yes yeah so the hip hop heads and the
puck the punk scene
got together and they were like no we're
going to do our own thing they're going
to come to they're going to hook it up
to the street light bro outside the d to
get the turntables and the dj popping
like turn tables human beatbox like yeah
we didn't we didn't have nothing you got
to do what you got to do yeah you use
what you had
exactly
you know a lot of people grab their
phones they do their videos they do
their edit some stuff like that there's
a lot of editing software up there
that's free
yeah it's kind master you can do a lot
of stuff that actually right now so if
you don't have the the money to go buy a
yeti or something like that
you have the passion people are going to
see your passion yeah if you're willing
to invest in yourself after you get some
money yeah then people will see your
your passion and you'll reinvest keep
reinvesting yeah and that's the thing
that's that's the part i do agree with
attic with the whole you know once once
you you're comfortable with everything
then yeah you got it you got to reinvest
you got to step up because the
competition to this point the
competition is fierce and stuff like
that but i want to keep pushing on this
story this is amazing with a pso radio
so you're building this community
and like what's what's the vibe because
like as far as the interaction like how
do you know obviously you're getting the
check coming through which is dope but
like how do you know this thing is is
kind of growing and maybe taking on a
life and then did that transition
straight into gamertag yeah so how for
me at that time i remember
i will have like my my discussions i'll
record with with different people from
the ps4 community and i remember the
first time uh ign picked it up and they
did a whole article about our show like
about my show saying oh there's a show
about fannie star online like from the
it was
during the the dreamcast section that
they had
yeah yeah so they they post they posted
that then other sites posted and this is
again back in the early days on social
media
and i'm like okay so
creating this is how i figure it out
creating content
you just got to do it and not
concentrate so much on like yo i'm gonna
you know work on the click bait so i can
get the buzz and this that's your turn
i'm thinking long term and at the same
time i'm having fun
and look i didn't know ig was gonna pick
it up and this is early 2001. talked
right so by them discovering my show and
other sites it helped me get a new
audience and also helped me to
to get more listens and i got paid from
that because i'm having fun with it man
i'm saying so yeah so that's what
happened then fast forward
you know i i decided like i wanted to do
a a general just every a show about
everything so it was called uh game
voice originally
i was to launch it on 9 11.
and then 9 11 happened
that i had to push him like no like i
was in new york you know so it was just
a weird vibe you know if i would have
launched it so
i fast forward to that
then i found out that xbox and nintendo
they were launching their
uh they're launching their consoles but
they were going to have hands-on events
in new york two two months after 9 11.
right okay so i went to
the microsoft event it's called xbox
unleashed and exactly
20 years is going to be on november 2nd
yes right now coming up so i have a
special show that i recorded with my
brother because we talked about
the event yeah you know i was at that
time i was
hardcore all about nintendo i was super
mad that sega shut down
all right so i'm going to this event
like not knowing anything about xbox but
i have my tape recorder
and my video camera because i'm like yo
i'm gonna i'm gonna record some cool
stuff and put it on my on my new show
yeah so i go there
to xbox unleashed this was a 48-hour
competition you go there and you play
these games i think it was there alive
uh project god
they had halo they had a couple of games
there
and uh and if you win you you win a free
trip to cancun you win a free car you
get like xbox games a bunch of stuff so
um i
pulled up oh yeah
and it was like sponsored by taco bell
oh it was lit yeah i remember your mr ha
had the taco bell joint king member yeah
i remember everything he said yeah this
is official this is when the money
and i'm like yo i straight up went to
xbox i'm like yo can i get a media badge
like recover from my show they didn't
ask me for business cards enough oh it
was lit but it wasn't the people they
gave me they gave me some random
homelessness
they gave me a badge
wow and and from there yo i met the
whole team i was in the vip
original yeah original and i have a
crazy story about him later like after
that yeah you're going there yeah yeah
yeah
that's that's the after dark iop going
to be that way
so then so i'm there recording content
at the same time i'm competing yeah
competing with my brother because i was
like yo i want to win a free trip to
cancun
i'm trying i'm trying and there was one
game that i was just terrible at and it
was tony hawk pro skater 2x that was the
the xbox version
but there was this one guy that he just
mastered that game and couldn't i
couldn't there was no way to beat him
yeah he even went back home took a
shower took a break came back and he was
still number one that's how good it was
so then so then boom then at the end of
the 40-hour competition jailer and
they're in the team they were like hey
come to the room okay and it was only 10
of us out of the thousands of people
that were there that stayed in 48 hours
so we sat down and he's like
we're going to give you guys each of you
guys a free xbox
wow
with all with all the games and
everything and i'm like yo here broke as
hell
eating taco bell the whole weekend
shout out to the taco bell the mountain
dew that was powering you through and
i'm like yo i can't believe i'm getting
a free console what in the world right
so
i get it early
i was home i went to also the nintendo
uh gamecube they had an event it was
called q club okay that was also on tour
that had a dj and everything too so i
also recorded the same exact thing that
i did for for xbox and i did it for this
one absolutely so then i get a random
call
i picked up and it was xbox we're like
hey how you doing danny hey we're gonna
have an event times square we would love
for you to go the big one
so i was like all right i went there you
know i i got there probably saw him yeah
we probably saw him this is so crazy so
i was i was in line
inside inside of toys r us and for those
who don't know because of 9 11 and also
towards russia wasn't fully open
xbox had to get permission from the city
of new york to to have that event there
wow you know what i'm saying so when i
when i went inside um
they were like hey guys what's up hey by
the way you guys going to meet bill
gates don't give him your resume
uh but you guys are gonna play and the
media's gonna ask you questions because
you guys already have the console i was
like all right
so if you go online and search danny
pena bill gates and you'll see pictures
of me with bill gates online yeah this
is the time where i had hair at that
time
we went across the street wwf at that
time had a restaurant yes and the rock
the rock was hosting that event the
launch event so i was there like it was
handbill gates you know launching the
the console
and when i was there i was talking to
jay adler and uh and some of the folks
from
from xbox they were not happy with ign
during that time because ign what
happened had had a um a premium service
called ign insiders
yes where you had to pay to read some
other like the premium content which i
was like hey it's cool like for me i was
like whatever you know hey trying to
make that money
but
they posted all the reviews for xbox was
only on ign insiders so the majority
people couldn't really get their
coverage
so he was like yo i'm disappointed like
we sent them everything and all the
reviews are there like how people are
going to read that right so i was like
damn that's crazy so so yeah i just want
to mention that but the other was cool
he was like he was like yo treat them
right yo they're they're good they're a
huge fan of ours like he he took us dude
we met everybody at the event everybody
so if you go online on youtube i mean
the quality looks crappy as hell but
if you go online and search
xbox launch 2001 you'll see me even in
that video bro
yeah it's nuts that's nice i wanna i
wanna shout out because i wanted to
paint the picture because you know for
us
you know xbox was so new in the game and
you said some some key points you know
from the standpoint obviously i'm kind
of like you i was a sega kid they kind
of came out the game you know xbox i was
like eh microsoft i don't know you don't
say it was kind of you got to feel
what's going on but the energy that
you're painting is that that hunger
because they were trying to establish
themselves right then new york city you
know solve like we remember that was an
event the times square thing
saw this it was target yeah no that was
that was crazy because the thing is
king will remember we didn't have our
cup we like we we had already
pre-ordered our consoles right so for us
going to the event was just going to the
event just to be there because we
weren't going to stand online to get
consoles because we're getting ours the
next day so
but that was that thing was like oh my
god this is like the biggest event we've
ever been to where it's like
a couple of months after 9 11 you know i
mean the yankees lost the world series
like oh yes
i was like
xbox was the thing for me that was like
this is this is my moment for the year
right
this and like metal gear solid 2 or
whatever um
ah nah man it was it was an amazing time
because i remember how i was meeting
yeah
and it was like he got this experience
yeah i'm sorry
but the energy around it for something
brand new that nobody has seen yet
nobody i i think i think the reviews for
halo has started coming out we started
getting the like the nines and the tens
the yeah i was like wait a minute hold
up this could be something and we were
like we were the ones honestly i wasn't
skeptical of it i was excited for it i
was like cool sega's out the game like
these guys are coming in all in i
can i say that am
quick and i noticed the chat everybody's
like trashing ign yo they're cool peeps
man you're gonna understand that back
then
the the business model back then was
different so ign was doing that with
every concert it was not yes it wasn't
like just the hate on xbox yeah yeah
yeah this was they did that with
gamecube they did it with everything and
remember management back then it was
different like yeah boys are different
they're they're they're fam you know
they're really cool but it happened you
know i just kind of no no we keep it
real that's what it was and at the end
you know new kids on the block and i
remember for for me it's funny you said
that solve with the nines and that's
what pushed me over because i knew they
had some ports i knew they had a couple
of second games that i was interested in
but when halo reviewed how halo reviewed
and people were talking about it with
the reverence and this killer app and it
never i needed to know what was the
craze that was what pushed me over king
i want you to get your balls off because
you was around you know what i'm saying
during this joint like you remember the
energy well the thing with it is he's on
the inside and
i'm telling you he's probably rubbing
shoulders yeah probably
um that other experience where i think
give me uh let me know if i'm wrong each
game that you played you accumulated a
certain amount of points when you was at
that microsoft yes right yes okay so i
remember playing out there you were
there oh my god so you probably saw me i
was there with my hat everything like
yeah
i think i would have tried a little bit
harder
yeah i remember playing project golf and
racing and and all the all all of the
launch games that were there right so
you had to accumulate a certain amount
of points to move on to the next round
or whatever and i probably didn't work
that whole i didn't go and play the
whole weekend because i had to work or
whatever yeah but when we did the
42nd street the time square thing
um
the buzz was because bill gates was this
enigma yes
you know he was this billionaire
philanthropist playboy he was bruce
wayne to us at that point in time
and it's like bruce wayne is is it the
same
is he serious is he real
and but the stuff the tech that was
inside the box was nuts
yeah they made sure that every store
like uh eb games
uh electronic boutique kb was it kbc
storage yeah kb was down there yeah yeah
was that still around i don't know yeah
yeah but if you think about if you just
think about the lengths they went to to
promote that console
like and that launch
for some type of product was brand new
yeah the product was brand new on the
market it was like they they came out
they it's funny because they came out
like you expect microsoft to come out
like with a big bang we believe in this
100
it was it was it was kind of
and the and that was why the reaction
from the press was weird because it was
like yo these guys are showing you
they're all in but nobody believed them
yeah yeah they didn't believe him
because this was the billionaires boys
club yeah
was they doing it on a whim
where as you had sony that just got in
and they just dethroned sega they just
you know slaughtered the street
and you had nintendo that was the old
hats like now we ain't giving up and it
was really going hard at you know the
nintendo 64 and stuff like that
this just when we got the xbox then you
first turned on halo and you hit that
little white button and your light
turned on shout out to the duke
that's when i was in all the way in the
light
i said i've never seen that before and
that's when i'm all the way in so i know
you see i'm on the outside but you had
the media
i worked to get to get that i was like
yo what's up
shout out to shoot your shot though that
was crazy yeah honestly i think if i was
not if i i've not would have done that
none of we i would have been talking to
you guys shout out to your moms for
giving you the confidence to always
shoot your shot yeah yeah that's that's
real man that goes back to that yeah
when he was doing the the
arcade games with the controller and he
was making money she had that belief in
you so she gave you those wings so when
you're in a situation you had those
beliefs to do that now if a parent was
to shoot you down
you probably don't have that confidence
within yourself to say um can i get a
media badge yeah yeah that's right
that's the that's the hustle spirit too
your mom's gonna give you those
so look man again tremendous you're
getting this popping off so you do it
again big coverage all this is going on
they call you back now how does this now
transition into gta how does this now
how do we go to game attack radio so i
was i i had that itch of bringing the
radio show back you know uh because back
then when i did pso radio and game voice
it was like no schedule it was like
whenever i feel like i just you know
so um
and again remember i mentioned that i've
got featured on ign and a bunch of media
sites with pso radio i it happened again
with game voice because i uploaded the
content that i recorded from xbox
unleashed
uh from that event and everybody got
picked it up this is before the launch
of xbox so everyone was like super
excited you know i recorded interviews
with the fans i even recorded my first
big interview with xbox nice about uh
about halo and about the consoles i was
super nervous
so but before that that was actually my
second event that i went to my first
first event ever yeah was uh for was for
the sega dreamcast the launch of sega
net this is oh
yeah so that was that was my first one
yeah yeah so then fast forward uh i'm in
miami now
i'm talking to my brother i'm like yo we
should launch a show now i'm talking to
him like around
200
no november this november december of
2004. okay i was like yo we should we
should launch a show we should launch a
podcast because you know podcast is like
super underground you know it's easy
enough for people to download
and i told them yo we should launch a
show called gamertag radio he hated the
name
he's like i
it's the internet like why are we gonna
call it radio i'm like yo i just
something is telling me do you i really
like his catch
we launches it will be like the first
xbox live radio show like that's how i
was thinking back then
he said all right so we launched the
show
and uh within 24 hours
again media picked it up
message boards was everywhere
xbox
even contacted me wow and one of the
interviewers for xbox.com oh and
it's live so if you go to internet
archive around that time
and put uh you know uh i forgot krista
trixie trixie 360 back then she was the
one that interviewed us wow and she even
surprised us when you turned on
the xbox the original xbox console yeah
on the dashboard
it popped up like i even have the
screenshot uh we interviewed gamertag
radio so we were like the first
of the first uh content creators and
podcasts in general just on the
dashboard of xbox yeah back in the early
years yeah yeah insane so i saw that i'm
like yo
mad people seeing this you know it's
crazy so crazy but here when things got
a little bit crazy for me what happened
when it went left was this is what this
is when
xbox is already planning on launching
the xbox 360. so they did um an event
that were recorded with with mtv
so uh this was more for the mainstream
audience you know they now xbox figured
out how to work with the mainstream
audience and also with the with the
hardcore audience right so
they recorded that event and this is the
first time that people were gonna get to
see xbox 360. right so i found out my
friends went to that event
so
the event was recorded on a thursday
night i contacted them on friday
recorded a
and interview them and i record first of
all i recorded all my interviews
through the halo 2 lobby
of xbox live so that's how i do my
interviews recorded and released as
audio so i recorded it through them and
they're like yo
the 360 is going to have call of duty
they talked about perfect dark zero like
a perfect zero cameo yeah an exclusive
and remember
the video hasn't been out yet oh so they
had to pre-record it and you got it
i got it first so i posted it
i posted that on
i posted it for like it was up like
maybe 30 minutes on the website i can't
imagine yo hype that you yo
i can't imagine the cease and desist
that it might have went down
let's go i posted it up because
originally mtv told them yo tell your
friends so everybody to watch it you
know yeah so she's telling me all the
scoop everything things that people that
had no idea about about xbox 360. wow so
i released the show
and then
i get an email from xbox actually i'm
not going to mention the name of the
person
i get an email from xbox and they were
like
danny can you remove that because we
want to surprise the audience you know
it hasn't been announced like
you know you're not going to get in
trouble but i was nervous because i
didn't want them to get in trouble
either you know what i'm saying
so so i took it off
but it was already too late every media
outlet picked it up
it was on on different websites
different forms the back then the big
one was uh team xbox form
and that's how
paris found out about gtr oh
that's crazy yeah so
that went around
and if you go to the itunes like really
deep look oh my gosh it's still there
it's still there the article even on
game spot yeah it's everywhere it says
something about like we were the first
website to talk about perfect dark zero
so
yeah so i did that and i went to my
first c3
i created a media kit
and at that time again there was no
smartphone so i had to like tell people
i will call it internet radio show
because if i'll call it podcast at the
time they would be like damn so i need
an ipod like people oh the connotation
yes good point good point so before that
there was no podcast on itunes still you
know what i'm saying so when i go to to
e3 with my brother dude i wasted all my
money on the media kid
and i only had
20 bucks for the week of v3 wow because
i paid hotel rented a car my first time
in l.a like you know
you know everything you know what i'm
saying go ahead who that kind of reminds
me of what um
uh
man i forgot his name already uh we just
had them all just had them oh dino
yeah shout out to jake
yeah
he ate what did he say uh cereal yeah he
had cereal bro he was outside like i
know how it is like you know you gotta
be there and it's like it's the event
it's the biggest thing in gaming for us
e3 was the mecca e3 was this fictional
place where all this great stuff is
happening we would get the cassette what
is it the vhs tape of the year later to
watch it and we'd be like man you know
it really wasn't public facing so it was
such a dream to go there so for you to
take the initiative trust me i know
because i've been out the e3 by myself
that i just had to go you know saying
but to you to go out there and to really
put the dedication out there to say yo
you know what
you know funds ain't really the highest
but i need to be here i need to promote
the thing continue to start
yeah i remember oh sorry i was just
going to say something like i remember
that that e3 that because uh they they
dragged me to the second one
and um because kog went to the first one
by himself yeah and then yeah they
dragged us
yeah they saw hey similar to you daddy
they saw me
on the xbox one dashboard and i'm with
major nelson i met phil spencer 2015.
that's what i how i met bill stillwell
that that was the year
when um xbox back compat was announced
and nobody knew so i was talking to bill
and those guys i didn't know who bill
was i was like who's this guy you know
it's phil it's this so then at the
announcement i'm like yo you was holding
on to that like yo how did you do it
because we come from the era where you
know how like with the genesis you have
the power based converter with the mass
system in it you always have to have the
hardware in it but the react like dave
was doing something so revolutionary
that when the announcement happened and
mikey bar and those guys and phil
announced it the pop in the crowd was so
crazy the energy was nuts oh
that was the year that of the backwards
compatibility yeah 2015 was my first
yeah that was the backwoods because i i
to this day i've been to
three maybe four e3s i think it's four i
don't know
there is nothing like look do you need
to go to e3 every year absolutely not
but yes you do
at least you need to at least go one
yeah
listen guys don't listen to anything i'd
excited
you have to go every time that you can
because every year is a different
experience none of those experiences
blended together for me all right every
time i was out there i had a different
corvette stuff was low you was outside i
know i know yourself but
let's focus get back with daddy because
again i want to hear this he's outside i
get it times is rough brother you out
there twenty dollars in the pocket yo we
we were eating
dollar burgers uh from mcdonald's salute
to the dollar baby flew to the value
menu
let's go danny you wasn't media you
wasn't inside nope
nothing nothing yo i hustle to get in so
wow talk to the way how i got in my
brother and i we have the same name so
his name is daniel my name is danny
right so when we
uh my friend uh helped us to to register
they only gave us one media badge so
they put daniel pena
and i didn't have no badge
let's go
hold my eyes
no that's how i did it so
my friend was like hey look i have
another badge this is before the whole
scanning thing yeah they used to scam
they would be hardcore with that so i
was a totally different person at daddy
three
different person yeah yeah i had to yo
there was no other way
i had
[Laughter]
yeah the statue of limitations you good
brother you're good
so i had to do i had to do that for a
while so uh so yeah yeah so i did that
and look no appointments no no
invitations to like events parties
nothing so i had to like
go to every booth and give him my media
badge and i was so disappointed at the
end of that e3 yeah yo i didn't have i
didn't get no access the only access
that i had was xbox they're like oh the
community hey come on yeah
and that's it that's it
but you had swag though
yes i had swag but still dude
i was still disappointed man because i
wasted all my money you know what i'm
saying
yeah yeah but he still wastes a lot of
money yeah if it was swag i'd be like
yeah i'm happy with swag but my focus
was i wanted them to see the bigger
picture about podcasting you know right
progress yeah yeah so
you hear people yeah it's real you hear
that people it ain't about the swag it's
about the business
long term vision continues
and then why did you bring up the swag
you already know when they let the
republican swag left but at that period
of time when when he's going in the
early days swag was given out to all the
media dudes because they wanted to woo
you and they needed to have you give
good press about this stuff right yeah
he had swag but it wasn't about the swag
it was about his see i didn't learn it
was about business until he said
something so yeah yeah so like you're
saying there's a little frustrated at
this point i'm assuming because again i
know the feeling
i got into fan fest but i couldn't get
into any other conference you couldn't
go to any other
show party you know boobs and stuff and
you know how that was but you ain't
really well you at least you had the
media badge but for people that don't
know like if you didn't have that many
you're waiting on them long lines to see
them
games and them they think yeah
they think all the e3 is playing games
over rose works
bro your feet is hurting
yeah people
i see this common like uh you know
comment uh miss thing where people think
that just because you get accepted to e3
you get into all the conferences
like you have to get accepted to every
conference individually yeah okay so
i'll be about to say about that yeah i
mean no it's not that at all i remember
my first one when i went with you guys
and it was like i you guys had already
been there once or twice
and i you know we go we get access to
the event but we didn't have access to
anything else didn't get into fan fest
or whatever and it was super
disappointing because i'm like way down
like you can't get most you can't get
into anything yeah you were frustrated
yeah i was super frustrated because i'm
like okay this is gonna be it i we don't
even have access to be able to talk
about the games because you have to wait
on such a long line and then they were
being sticklers about like they didn't
want you jumping up to the front just to
capture footage they're like no you have
to be on the line and when you come up
then maybe we'll let you capture
something when it's your turn so after
waiting three hours to play said game
that's when you can maybe capture
something right so it was like it was
frustrating because it's like all right
every single day that i'm in there three
days or whatever the case may be i have
to pick one thing that i'm willing to
wait on yeah and sacrifice the whole day
for it sacrificed the whole day for yeah
so it was i mean yeah absolutely
absolutely and the last one i'll say
before i give it back to danny was just
that you know for me the first i wanted
to be in to be the conference was
important you know being there when it's
announced that's the key attic and me we
we really cared about that
king as well we cared about it and not
having access was so frustrating because
don't give me no disrespect to the main
show the three days later that you go on
the floor but it's something to be there
when like phil is on stage saying
whatever or when you're laying in there
yes
i i will never forget like
there was a year that
the conference was looking spooky
like i already booked the tickets booked
the hotel we wouldn't do hotel at that
time but i was like i was literally
debating i was like
cog i think i might cancel everything
i don't remember i'm not gonna go out
there and sit in the hotel because i
because at the end of the day i didn't
get in fan fest that year so i didn't
have
and we didn't really know anyone at
microsoft so i didn't have the connect
to get into the conference so i was like
i'm literally going to go there go to e3
which in my opinion like the floor
and like unless you have uh like you
know your basic you know uh interviews
and stuff the floor is the worst part
it is it is because there's too much
walking around i feel like i'm dying 24
7. there's too many people shout out to
the comfortable sneakers you need
conferences the after parties that is
the highlight of e3 and then i'm sitting
there i'm like
i'm gonna cancel cars like don't cancel
it yeah but remember it's like uh so i
was all right so i'll go at the last
minute the day before i'm already in e3
at the at the bnb whatever we was at
that time the day before i got
we i got away into the conference like
literally the last minute he was able to
get it because it's a joy but we got we
gotta get back to daddy so continue your
story so so again frustrated money low
so what what you do from that point bro
uh i was just frustrated man at home and
and still kept on going you know doing
re doing my show i recorded with my
brother and everything and then
two months after that
uh we found out that apple added
podcasts to the platform and i'm like oh
my god this is gonna be huge
so now our listenership grew
like crazy right so just out of
curiosity what yeah what year was this
this was summer of 2005. okay so
steve jobs on stage announced podcast
is added to itunes
so
that right there change the game helped
us because now the people that i met at
e3 they've never heard a podcast right
back then in order for you to get
podcasts you had to download a
third-party app that was created from
the community from like the podcasting
scene
to get podcasts so podcast originally
started
september of 2004.
it was for hardcore yeah hardcore heads
i love that so
we had we had like directories back then
uh it was called podcast ali podcast
pickle
that was the only way or go to the
website of that of that show that was
the only way for this to listen to the
show so
imagine me
hearing that itunes added podcast dude
it was like
i was like let's go
yeah so a year after that now i'm
getting contacts left and right
let's work let's work with it but it was
taking that risk in 2005 when i went
over there you know i'm saying like even
this even before the launch of the xbox
360 i'll i will go to a lot of like the
tournaments like mlg and halo and
everything right so i met a lot of the
pro players that back then you know
shout out to t-square absolutely and i'm
talking to him
and i'm like yo let's do an interview
he's like alright so we recorded the
entry through the phone right and he
said to me danny i have um someone
filming is it okay they're recording it
so i'm like yeah he didn't mention what
it was at that time
fast forward he tells me oh danny that
interview that you did is going to come
out and it to be true life
yo
entry true life and it was going to air
during the this they had like a video
game week
on on mtv and that was the same week
with the xbox 360 launch
so
so i'm watching the video and it said a
local radio station interviewing him
instead of podcast so right there again
again i was frustrated i'm like oh my
god
but
people that people that that heard my
voice and knows that was me and my
brother they were like shouting us out
oh danny on on mtv true live like uh so
so you was daddy your empty true life
right
yeah yeah
so so like little things like that like
i will get buzz here and there media you
know but at the same time i'm networking
learning like learning what to do like i
got connected with oneup.com back then
they even asked me tips like yo danny
we'd like to do a podcast for for for
our site help give us some tips and i
was just out there like trying to help
you know i'm saying ign i've met people
from there you know just networking and
then dude
throughout the years yo i just managed
to
meet up with everybody in the industry
man everybody and still to this day
people will hit me up like hey you know
like you should work in the industry and
they're they're all retiring and
everything i'm saying like uh j adler
hit me up ah that's what's up oh geez
i spoke to um you know peter moore i met
him multiple times right this year
i don't get i never get no peter moore's
stories because that's that's my guy
before i know what k is filled dominance
max and we play respect but i'm a peter
moore i'm a dream cass sega kid like
that's my heart tell me this peter
monster give me one
yeah
yo you know i had him on a show
this is when he retired from gaming so
he at that time he was the ceo of
liverpool yes he was he was out of the
country somewhere uh in europe
and uh and he hit me up he called me and
he did a a 45 minute conversation about
the 20th anniversary of the sega
dreamcast it's on the show oh i got to
go digging the crates nobody to this day
no other podcast nobody got peter moore
bro i like not like that
yeah so we did that i also did uh
the 20th anniversary of xbox with robbie
bach he was involved with uh with xbox
back in the days that came a couple
weeks ago
so yeah man so i'm telling you
networking helped me to to get the name
out there man and then having the crew
you know throughout the years
shout out to paris lillian also peter
toledo like yo those are my bros man how
did you form how you form voltron talk
like hot like they cuz obviously uh
paris heard from you right here for you
when that that where the league happened
from the yeah
and they told how did you connect with
with peter how did that go down so with
paris paris i met first so it was in
sometime in 2006 i got invited to go to
an event this is my first
travel event that company who fly me so
it was
yeah so it was for lord of the rings ea
was working on this rts game uh battle
from middle of birth i think it was
called i don't know
yeah i was way back so
i got invited to that and uh i recorded
a video interview with my friend
uh
what's his name oh my god from chris
palladino from uh
from the video game show dreamstation.cc
and we did that
and uh and they posted up the video and
paris was home and he saw
that he was watching that video he's
like oh my god so these guys created a
show
and they were at xbox dude i want to do
that so
his co-host at that time hit me up
i was on vacation
and he was like hey can you give me tips
on how to do it so i couldn't reply for
like a good week or two
so when i came back i saw that email and
he replied angry his calls
that is hell
cursing me out like oh you didn't help
me and you know oh daddy
he was hollywood daddy they
you know what i'm saying so paris hit me
up apologizing like yo dude i'm so sorry
that's that's not my style like i don't
do that you know but i would love to get
tips from you man like you know and
i'm like oh dude bro i i get it so we
started talking
and we became really good friends man
really good friends so he launched he
launched his show uncle gamer radio
after um and yeah we always
we never see each other as uh competi
like competition we always helped each
other like i remember one time paris hit
me up like yo danny i got this big
interview with ken levine about bioshock
and i and i told him
dude nobody has that put it as podcast
exclusive nobody has
put that word in it exclu let's go walk
it in you worked your butt off to get
that breach do that pretty i will always
doing that you know yeah i know a lot of
a lot of the mainstream outlets were
like yo what the hell man danny's doing
this and this night like i know a lot of
them they're like i know they wasn't
feeling you bro cause you you were
breaking down so many bad what it is is
you you had the contacts and you had the
access you just didn't have as far as
the podcast died until it probably hit
apple and then you get more recognition
for eyes on you but you was already
moving and shaking more than these
bigger outlets so they they had to view
you as a threat on some level because
you're just getting all this exclusive
content consistently like that's crazy
yeah it's it's you know like the stories
that i got
it's insane like yo like i remember
yo me and paris we'll go to e3 again
we're not he was not part of gtr at that
time okay and i'm like yo paris i heard
this will party
around here let's go for uh for this for
this game for this game yes let's let's
dig let's dig so he's out there at e3
doing this thing i'm doing my thing like
recording and then at night we get
together
and then yo we figured out like okay
where where is that where is that we're
not it we're not invited you better
fight you don't even got the value
how you doing though how you doing how
you get through the door so i mean this
is back then now it's gonna be way
harder but back then
i was like yo paris i found the location
let's go so we'll go you'll pull up
and be like oh yeah we're looking for
so-and-so they they told us to be here
and yo pr where the person in charge of
the door look at us
these cats are bs
yo
yo yo peterboy's inside yo they just
looking for
they didn't let this [ __ ] i was like oh
my god paris paris says you snitching
down yo yo
give it up yo this is good talk paris
i'll we used to do this we know what
you're talking about
but you know what you know what you know
why i bring that up because yo we were
hungry man people think
like i remember on us announcing
that we were gonna get
phil spencer on our show right a couple
uh two years ago right what's it last
year last year
and those people all they don't deserve
it i'm like no dude you don't know the
grind please that that not only me but
also paris and pete yo we grind
ourselves oh
i'm saying yeah
things like that
things like that motivated me to even
work harder man you know what i'm saying
like like dude here's another story
let's go that's a crazy one so
i get invited
to go to a dj hero event i was like hero
yes i'm gonna go
you know it's a it's during the week of
v3
you know i got invited and there was a
very like they were picky on who getting
invited to that right
so again i'm hustling paris hustling
like you know so
we go to this event and i told pat joe
come with me let's just see let's figure
out maybe i could get you in let's see
how it works so let's go he goes in he
goes with me to the event all right
checking the list yo the person that was
in charge of the of the list he's like
yo danny perry's assignment yo i need i
don't even know how to check the list i
already got you guys here man here
yo
me and paris look at you like yo we got
this we should go in there
we go in there and yo it was eminem and
jay-z performance for the first time
for formula the first time so we're in
the in the media slash vip lounge
and i'm like yo who is this like who is
this
yo this woman right right in front of us
you're beautiful your beautiful lady
right yo kim kardashian was right right
in front of a plane
and she's like waving like hey should be
in paris
yo what the hell
we were like yo
we were bugging you the party is crazy
back in the day too like they were like
crazy for us and we came later in the
game so i could only imagine that eric
king the parties
you would never see that now never never
i think my biggest moment i would shout
we were surrounded by celebs and like
athletes
wow bro
like people don't realize those e3 those
industry parties hit different i don't
have nothing in comparison to that my
biggest one was like i think it was like
a ea thing and it was like
brian erlacka barry sanders all at the
same spot you know it would we had a
couple of moments like that but nothing
to that effect so i could only imagine i
want to transition real quick because
you're talking to hip-hop and i'll be
remiss you know what i mean like people
don't understand like right now one of
the greatest podcasts in hip-hop right
now is string chance you know i'm gonna
shoot dj fm shout out to nori from
capone noriega
you have an amazing story in reference
to even helping
these guys get off the ground talk about
give some godfather drink champs real
quick yeah yeah so i i know uh his name
is dg effen yes uh a lot of people will
call my bad my bad i always mess up yeah
he get mad with that
so i know him because we used to go to
school together like i know again i used
to be involved with the hip-hop scene
back then so everybody in miami will
always help each other man you know so
so i they had a show on serious radio
but it was just like them talking you
know like the stories and they stopped
so
he knew i was always doing the hip the
hip hop and and gaming podcast right so
he's like
he will always ask me questions like hey
how's the show and i'm like yo
you have to launch this podcast
nobody nobody's doing the hip-hop scene
and you and especially nora you guys got
some crazy stories and then my guests
like
you have to do it he's like yeah let me
try so
he talked to nori nora he's like ah
that's for nerd
that left rack talk that queen talk
wasn't feeling it
back then again back then the hip-hop
scene they were seeing podcasts as like
a nerdy thing yup you know what i'm
saying so
i'm telling her for years so
two years passed by
and i i i went to a uh jay dilla
yeah it was a jade
weekend his mom was there uh
dude all the hip-hop heads um uh who
camp law was there
lucia let's get the legend
yeah i was dude i was surrounded with
fat joe oh come on squad let's go get it
show business
ditc the crates
diamond d was it
was it was for this thing
oh rhapsody was there oh
yeah and that was the year that was the
year she was she was nominated for a
grammy uh because he was in the kendrick
lamar album so we got to hang out and
chill yeah so it was dope though so i'm
there talking all these cats and let's
see nowhere in the infant i go yo we
gotta talk man at that time we signed a
deal with cbs radio okay right so it was
called play.it back back in those days
so i'm there chilling i'm like yo
nori i really want to introduce you guys
because i could get you guys in
through cbs i know you guys could do
this podcast thing man come on man and
nori was like
yo cbs cbs sounds dope man i don't know
yo it's the efn uh efn what do you think
about cbs yo yo that's a good look
hip-hop show like that right so get it
so so
i i got them and i introduced them
to to cbs wow and uh at cbs like oh
danny thanks hey by the way e all we
need is like a demo just send us a demo
we'll hear it and we'll go from there
so
efn and noah recorded a demo with fat
joke
and for those who don't know i i
promoted for fat joe's uh like shows
back then like i worked with big pine oh
slow so
so hearing i was like yo this is perfect
right so
so they were they sent them the demo yo
cbs like yo let's do it let's let's
let's do this podcast so they launched
the show called dream champs and the
rest is history
and the crazy the crazy thing is
uh what's his name and he does a lot of
interviews like with uh with artists um
oh my god what's his name man
old school journalist he has like
youtube ella wilson in them uh he has
like a crazy hair white dude oh my god
oh wait wait wait wait wait wait damn
you taking it back he said yeah i forgot
okay he's old school he's on school okay
he he does like this random interviews
like he will ask you and show you albums
like everything things that you that the
the artist would like yeah uh from back
then back in the day i can't remember
his name oh man uh
anyways he was into inauri and efn about
drink champs and he randomly like thanks
to godfrey and norah was like what the
heck godfrey what like and then he
surprised him with that and so it goes
around you know back then uh
back then nora will be like he will call
my show a game tag
thanks to godfrey the game tag for
helping out with the dream chat
between that podcast
so uh so yeah so from there
he uh they say in the chat nardwar is
that guy is that
yeah the chat saying
yeah
when i saw that video
that he mentioned my name i was like wow
i was not expecting he's a legend in
front of it journalist man this is crazy
man trip tremendous on the hip-hop by
the way i'm not leaving so oh no okay
okay okay
i gotta get a couple more questions i
appreciate you brother i gotta this is
this is this is true podfather talk and
like i said so much influence there i
wanna transition really quickly into um
the obviously wait i wanna finish off
with gamertag because as far as the um
you know you're doing this brother one
thousand episodes brother yo that's kind
of crazy
for us
and this is a fact for those in the chat
a fact
first
gaming podcast
now no other podcast has has reached
at that time
one thousand episodes i gotta give you
the golden emoji right now put the goats
up right now this is this is
this is gold talk right now you know
what i mean talk to him and and knew in
the space
gaming podcast didn't exist and that's
why it's like bro i was like i always
felt like we got to give danny's flight
like this is insane the amount of
influence and what's going on so talk to
me you culminated 1000 you got the
legendary phil dominus maximus irelia
spencer that we call him here in a row
amazing interview brother amazing
interview thank you yo that was
a year in the making
i i i mentioned a year before
we hit a thousand episode i contact xbox
like yo
i would love to have phil for a 1 000
episode that will be like legendary you
know i know you guys gonna have some big
things next year the consoles how we can
make that happen
and
dude it got approved
no lie
a month before before we hit
the 1 000 episode again remember i
contacted them a year going there looks
like they were busy you know with
multiple things but i was patient i'm
like
paris was the one
shot the parents said to said to me
because i asked in paris i want to do
something big for a 1 000 episode i just
don't know what it is i've been trying
to get phil again on our show he was on
when he took over xbox right um and uh
and i want to do it again because it's
been years so i'm like yo how can i get
phil on the show you know like
he's like yo just contact them
contact them i'm like you sure man he's
like yo go for it and he was the one
that pushed me to do it and i did it
took me again
almost a year wow and and the rest is
history dude when that episode actually
phil tweeted that yes i'm sorry
announcing it that he was gonna be on a
show he was in japan when he did that
in japan and uh and and he did like in
the middle of the night
and i remember
waking up like at three or four o'clock
in the morning because my phone was
going
and it was it was that yo like i was
like yo i can't believe phil is actually
bro it's doing this he's promoting it
he's mentioning our names like i was
like in shock man
yeah yeah so we did the interview 25
minutes uh i did it at this studio
called 360 nyc 368 in new york uh paris
did it at home
recorded for like a good half an hour or
so
and dude still to this day there was
articles written about that interview yo
there was a site multiple sites did six
or seven articles just when that
interview alone because we
we had nothing planned nothing ran we
had an idea of what we wanted to ask
like parasite things that we wanted to
ask right right
and
and they just went around dude it went
around like crazy man you know what i'm
saying like
you know for the key thing like you guys
i know you guys been getting a lot of
interviews on your show
yo the most important thing is
make your guests feel comfortable yes
super important man super important i'm
going to mention why in a few minutes
but
you know the more you let them feel
comfortable the more they're going to
open up and you could ask some some
great questions now no clickbait
questions but questions that you know
they're going to answer you know what
i'm saying so
every interview we had
it will go around because
of the vibe that's happening at that
moment i guess man so
a couple years ago
we paris and i got invited to go to time
for event
and we go there yo we were surrounded
by youtubers and streamers
that's when we noticed like yo
podcast like
like what's going on it's disappearing
what the hell so we looked at each other
and and we said yo we're dinosaurs yo
what the hell is going on oh wow the
train because back then
back then there was a lot of podcasters
we'll go to events and this is the first
time that we didn't see that right right
so
we go inside to the time for event and
it was respawned there vince some
paddler
everybody was there
yeah so
i'm there observing and i'm seeing
youtubers interviewing them
but they're acting crazy like that you
could tell they were super uncomfortable
and i'm like that's not our style we
always
been the same fact
we did we sat down no cameras it was
just my mic my recorder we sat down i
did three interviews with three
different devs
from respawn
yo
at the end of the night right we got the
word that
they said that was the best
interview
from the whole event they had a two two
day event wow media
and they had the concert like
consequences like influencers yeah and
they said that paris and i were the best
one of the both events
again making making them feel
comfortable man so they can open up so
for you guys are you guys getting a lot
of interviews do the same exact thing
because you ask them the right question
they're gonna answer it
because they feel comfortable and
because of that
most likely it would also get picked up
yeah and a lot of people don't think
that they always think of the of the
like the click baits and like the leaks
and right man great advice
you know it's crazy me and cole will
literally go over the questions for like
an hour before we have a big guess i'm
like is this too much should we go this
much into it yeah like we've literally
like went over questions before and then
like eliminate like five or six okay
maybe this is a little bit because it's
too much absolutely let's let's get rid
of that yeah because one thing is you
don't wanna
you made a great point it's great advice
danny which is we wanna make people feel
comfortable one of one of our goals is
you know we don't care away from what
you do to channel size and all that
stuff as long as you have something to
contribute in gaming you're a content
creator or you're a developer you know
i'm saying we want to celebrate you but
the thing about making them comfortable
because we don't want to put you in a
position where you want to say have to
say something while or something you
can't say so it's a it's a vibe right
it's an energy and i'm glad you said
that because yeah that that's something
we definitely pride ourselves on i never
had anything on the level of kudos that
you guys have but you know it is it is
always positive to hear
when your peers say hey that was a great
interview i really enjoyed our time yeah
you know with you
not to mention
people don't realize like the littlest
stuff people will pick up and give you
traction like yeah i remember you know
we was hitting jason wrong with some
with some hard questions
back to back and i was like let me ask a
question that's like this question
an easy question that you know he can
relax a little bit so i asked him what
is the game that you're particularly
excited about this year
he comes out and says oh it's not
announced yet man that blew for us
brother
yo every outlet ran for with it like it
was insane man with a quick shout out
shout out to paris he's like daddy stop
giving up the secrets he's like you
giving up too much gift
but yo here's the thing like i know i
know he's joking around but honestly
dude like that's not even a secret
that's like annoying this is common
sense right yeah
our style is completely different you
know um if you look at anybody's uh
podcast our style
really isn't uh about
what you what do you have going on right
now what do we know right now what can
we get from you right now no it's about
your journey
yeah what
i would not know that you was in miami
as a promoter
you understand if i only concentrated on
what danny has going on right now i
wouldn't i know that your grandmother
purchased three atari 2600s when uh you
know e.t hit crash
i would not know that you got the uh
the nes with the original gun
you understand i would not know that you
started up a business all these stories
we had your mom's got that push if i
didn't dig deep off we if we didn't dig
deep into the facts
and real quick our content is completely
different from a lot of people's content
out there because we really
are not looking to make headlines yeah
that's the thing
i think that's the big thing when you
look at when you look at what danny was
saying about you
the youtubers going crazy understand the
other yeah
the big mistake people make is that they
still when they interview someone big
they still want to make themselves the
focus of of the interview as opposed to
what we do here and cog has been great
about it from the very beginning you
come on here to get your flowers you
come on here to get the red carpet
rolled out we want to know about you and
everything that you've done
and a lot of times these these other
places
it's still about like you say the
clickbait whatever it becomes about the
interviewer i'm like why would you do
that like right why would you not
build up the person that you have on the
show and it's just a different way of
thinking it's just completely weird well
what it is and i'm gonna give it to you
attic is it's to me i look at it it's
it's short-term growth versus long-term
growth right that's what i was going to
say yeah i think i think he's going out
and it was good at it i'll let you go
okay a lot more people value what can
happen to them right now and not what
that happened to them in a couple years
right they'll come up there they see you
know if i can get if i could trick
someone into saying something you know
they get a big interview then they'll
get picked up and and i'll grow but what
they're not seeing is you know you made
that person uncomfortable because you
know you ask questions that you knew for
a fact they wouldn't be able to answer
and not to mention god forbid you
tricked them into saying something
because that happens all the time
now that whole company most likely about
the blacklist right yeah that happens
that happens
and the thing is too we've had scoops
we've gone interviewing on on the show
floor we're doing this stuff and we've
had stuff come out
and that maybe inadvertently they didn't
intend to but we never let let anyone
and it's like hey can you put that out
and yeah if i went for the big story now
i can leave that you know what i'm
saying but no you put out of respect you
pull those things out and you try to
make the person feel comfortable i'm
going to give you guys go ahead go ahead
i was going to say i had a video once
i'm not going to say what it was and who
it was but i made a video and i was
contacted by a developer from microsoft
to take it down yeah
like you know i i was talking to a
fellow youtuber and he told me to leave
it up
and i was like look bad i was like i
value the relationship with that company
more than i value the view because that
video was doing crazy it was at like 4
000 views in like an hour yeah and they
asked me to take it down and i i didn't
delete it i privated it but i was just
like you know like i value the
relationship that i could have with that
absolutely and
and the game's still not out i'll say
that no doubt okay
no i'm gonna give you a couple examples
of interviews that
is one of my favorites but also i feel
like the the guests opened up so much
that i was not
expecting them to say that so
you know it took me 10 years to get
reggie on the podcast 10 years 10 years
i tried
so many different ways to see to see if
we could get reggie fizzame former
president of nintendo of america on the
show
and uh he finally said yes
after he retired
and we sat down and he opened up and
started talking about growing up in the
bronx like he
he was like yo like he got robbed with
his brother and like
nobody nobody has ever heard
nobody are those stories
and i'm hearing this i'm like yo this is
a gem like this is like
stuff that i would love for people to
learn absolutely about man because
people don't know the the history how
new york used to be back
you know seeing that from an exact same
thing
blessed man like that was amazing so
then another one
you know i interviewed kendall reeves
last year for cyberpunk right so
i
had my questions there
but yeah because i i had an interview
for forte mundo
i had like two or three questions that
was written from telemundo that that i
told them okay i'll read that but
there was going to be a couple questions
that i want to ask
and the one
that stood out the most of the whole
interview i asked him how was that
moment coming out on stage and seeing
all the fans at the xbox press
conference seeing you
the main character of one of the biggest
games of the year and he was like he
smiled
and he's like dude i've never
experienced that in my life that was one
of the
biggest highlights of my career guess
what
after i was doing that interview his
agent
his agent let's go contacting me
directly to danny
out of all the interviews that he had
that day
that was the best interview that came
out he loved he loved it he opened up he
was super excited
hype you know what i'm saying so
that's the thing that i'm even my
fiancee tells me danny i don't know how
you do it but
every person you interview
is a different vibe
ah brother you gotta go
you gotta tell me paris paris is good
with that too you know pete but we
learned we learned that
just mastering and and and just helping
each other out like you know
we'll we'll talk like hey who should we
ask where she asks this and this and
that and
and look the flow just just fought
yeah yeah i remember paris talking about
uh the time that he had to on the spot
interview i think bonnie ross it was oh
the body runs throughout the world
where you lost your voice
that was the learning experience was
like you know what
step back for a second but like this is
a human being just like me they just
they bleed the same way that i do the
everything so just remember that and
just try to be as calm as you possibly
can because i'm gonna tell you right now
when cog wanted wanted me and king to be
on here king is a lot more
he's a lot more like he's he's loud
as you saw in the pre-show i'm not i'm
not that generally i'm good at speaking
but i'm not that and i was like i don't
know if i could do this car i got to be
on here and
it just after a while you just you're
not afraid of it anymore like if we you
know god when we get filled on whoever
whoever we get on here the vibe is the
same way it's like you're just a human
being and we want to find out about this
what you've done in this amazing space
that we all love and and it just flows
like it just flows and it's natural in a
way that i never thought i would get you
them ryan came on i i mean
kick that one
[Laughter]
or gig you're hilarious oh i do want to
move moving forward because we i don't
want to kill this time but at the end of
the day you know we got that we got
these stories get gamertag you know i
want to get into new stuff but i do want
to celebrate one thing obviously you
know how important was it for you you
know what i mean as far as being not
only the first
gaming podcaster but also the first
latino to be inducted into podcast hall
of fame brother
uh it means a lot to me man because
again you know i went through a lot
back in the days you know um growing up
especially in new york um
and not having the money to to buy the
equipment you know i i bought a a
computer
in my mid-20s man like super late
uh because i just didn't have the money
you know i had to get a student loan and
that's how i started using my uh i
created my show back then because of
that so
seeing that
and
also just having fun with my podcast man
you know uh
it me the show means a lot to me man
like look now
i'm i started working at g4
just been it's gonna be now a week you
know and
seeing that and all the stuff that i
learned from the show
it means a lot it's now
i want to see the next con the next
generation of content creators and even
podcasters too to do everything and take
it to the next level i want you to be
even better than me man you know and uh
and seeing look seeing
everything that's been going on with not
only with me but my brothers you know uh
pete and paris like dude i cried when i
saw paris on
stage with yeah showcase man because yo
people don't know the struggle that we
went to man you know like that moment
that video you people got to see
of paris excited about cyberpunk at that
time at e3 yeah you know i did that
because
paris was going
he was going through so much during that
time man and
that moment for me was special because i
whined my i want my brother to be happy
man and be excited and i want the world
to see that so i recorded that
and i posted it online and those videos
went viral yeah i wasn't thinking of
like oh click bait and i was thinking
like yo i want to know if my brother is
good celebrate him you know so
so seeing him on stage dude i broke down
live live on the stream broke down
fantastic that's fantastic i broke down
when i got my award yeah you know um
again because people don't know when i
went through manchester united
and full circle man seeing
you know my face on a
billboard new york city let's go in new
york city
in times square man
i was like dude that was like
amazing man because i i just got
proposed like engaged i mean it proposed
my my fiance and that month came back
went to new york straight because i
wanted to see my billboard and she
recorded my reaction again i almost
cried again man people don't know the
stuff that i've been through man i've
seen that and i was there 20 years ago
with a tape cassette from that's the
same
spot same spot across the street where
toys r us used to be yes
see my billboard there dude that was
amazing man and and people don't know i
even tried to record an issue with bill
gates
uh and uh because the media was
recording and asking him questions i
have my tape recorder like this
right talking like even asking a
question he was answering one of the
questions while i was recording pr got
to see it yo they grabbed my tape
recorder took the tape and they're like
no yo but at that time i didn't know at
that time i didn't know
i didn't know at that time so things
like that dude things like that and and
you know the little sony silver one you
made me
i can't imagine the mindset you're
sitting there recording and then just
someone did they like ask you for it do
they take it themselves like yeah they
they just ran down on you they ran down
you pulled the chair
the black suits
definitely tucked and rolled
you know what you know why i want to
mention this i want to mention this is
super important for those are watching
dudes when i came into the industry dude
there was no latinos there was no
people of color involved
so it was it was hard for me man because
i felt alone there was no way for me to
learn about the industry like
how to get in like i had to do
everything on my own but when
i managed to figure it out
and i get people like paris hitting me
up and others content creators at that
time like yo how should i do i also
helped him up because i didn't have that
back then man that's the key i'm saying
so seeing where paris is at and and p
and tony and you guys and everybody else
dude that's helping the next generation
all gonna do the same exact thing that
we're doing you know what i'm saying so
that that's why getting that award
means a lot because
now i'm inspiring a whole new generation
dude you know what i'm saying yeah
if i could jump in for a second yes
please yeah um
to speak on that about about you know
how obviously you know being dominican
is super important to you and and i know
you've done work to sort of promote
gaming in santo domingo as well as in
the city like bringing different aspects
of gaming and kind of opening up you
know our cultures to it in a way that
they haven't been opened up before so if
you could talk a little bit about the
stuff that you've done in regards to
that like yeah
that means a lot to me man because um
you know after i i came back to the
states i haven't been in dr for a long
time you know and i went there
a couple years ago and i wanted to meet
the gimmick community i want to see how
it is now you know i know it's a lot of
playstations and xbox nintendo switch
nintendo games out there so
i met the gaming community and the one
thing that everybody was telling me like
yo we feel left out we feel left out
there's no
there's no way for us to learn how to
how to uh how to create content there's
no way for us to learn about development
danny you're in it how can you help us
how you can help our our community over
here
and uh i took that
and i had it in my head for for like a
good two three years man and i started
talking to my friends at unity
and i told them yo can we do like a free
workshop because there's a lot of
talented people in the american republic
how we could do that and uh and we went
and we did a whole free
workshop games developer game developer
day we called it and we did at one of
the biggest universities in the american
public
and i i talked about my story you know
there's a lot of people that never heard
of what i do right and after that dude
there was a whole line of people that
just want to talk to me take pictures
with me
um i showed them i showed them my story
i told them like look
ubisoft put us put us in the division
two game we're there our logos in the
game like meeting bill gates like i told
them all the story they never like wow
the the hall of fame story and
everything
so that's the thing that i've been
trying to do is
is inspired not only the content creator
side but also game developers man over
there
that day they were showing me all these
games that they made over there wow and
i'm like yo this could be on like
platforms big platforms consoles it's so
dope man and this other countries not
only the immigrant public but there's
other people
that feel the same way
so i've been trying my best to
contribute as much as i can to help just
latin america in general man yeah i'm
saying so salute
so that's that's that's that's the main
reason why i've been doing a lot of that
stuff man brother tremendous story
so many iconic moments
you've literally
interviewed or rubbed shoulders with the
best of the best the who's who
games media executive tv stars actors
the late great michael k williams i saw
that one um oh yes you know
yeah yeah rest in peace rest in peace
y'all call it and then you got john cole
esposito you know drink chance i mean
the accolades are so immense um i know
you've had a lot of of stories and we're
going to get you out of as far as our
top five that we always ask everyone but
before that i did want to ask you just
person so many stories it's so many
right but like
we said podcast hall of fame i'm
assuming that might be up there but like
give me just three
moments where you s you sat back and was
like
wow
that was amazing whether it be just
personal whether it be or just epic
stories across your journey for you
besides the interviews there's a lot of
interviews but
i remember
talking to pete
paris was not part of gt i was he was
doing his own thing at that time
i want to do a an event a event for our
community and uh we did that we rented a
club we did it multiple times right but
there was one year that we did it during
super bowl weekend in south florida okay
right
we had the event we had a 2k sponsor us
they were promoting a bioshock 2 at that
time
and we had tournaments call of duty
gears everything right but remember in
the middle of super bowl weekend there's
tons of events happening at that time in
miami right absolutely yo the day before
our event i go
and i search just to see what people are
talking about our event called community
vibes five okay i go there online
and
the miami new times
named us the number one super bowl party
in south florida remember wow we were
broke as hell we only had
enough money to
to work what we have for the event
and
one of the biggest newspapers in miami
put us as number one higher than pepsi
and playboy and like i was like what in
the like that's one of one of them
the second of course the the times
square build course like
iconic um and i don't want to mention
the the hall of fame because you know of
course of course of course
on that billboard yeah yeah you made it
you made it you made it
um and just and honestly just um
i think seeing seeing paris on stage man
because that i feel like that's that's
part of me man you know what i'm saying
that's your brother yeah yeah yeah yeah
seeing that was uh what was iconic man
brother tremendous history yeah we got
to get you out with the uh the question
we asked everyone in the realm this is
this is tradition i need lord danny's
top five video games or franchises of
all time holy smokes well fanny star
online of course that made you
um
you know i like the old school game so i
i have to say man final fantasy 6 aka
final fantasy 3 for the states like that
yes that is one of my job system right
that's when they first introduced me is
that the one with the map no that
yeah this is before seven came out got
you but yeah i mean that was the first
one that they introduced jobs right i
think no jobs have been in the franchise
like this entire time
jobs was in the original one okay um
yeah so we got this one
good sorry uh
uh jessa radio and radio future i want
that to bring it i want i want sega to
bring it back i don't know why they're
taking so long okay also
dude playing
the demo for the first time of bioshock
on the xbox 360 dude that was like
mind blowing time man i was like what
was it so sick
go check out hovers inside game pass
right now on uh probably games of gold
this month or whatever try hover okay
hover a little uh spiritual successor
it's you might like
the reason why i love that game look if
it wasn't for that game there would have
been no
no spider-man no ranch and collect that
the the like the design that they have
they learned the traffic they learned a
lot
one of my favorite games my insanity i
shout out to them
the
best game in my opinion for the xbox one
one it's very underrated and and right
and and though of course the witcher you
know which are awesome
but but that one dude i love like i hope
they bring it back no doubt
and i think they will and you know anna
wake is up there too you know brother
tremendous and last question i think i
know the answer to this but i still
gotta ask you this is just a one one off
favorite console of all time any
generation and why
that's so tough that's a tough one
there's one that made you that's one
that got you into it there's a lot you
got a lot you know what i i think i will
go with this man with the sega dreamcast
the reason why is i feel like that
system was sought ahead of his time yes
way ahead of this time wait dude
i remember
playing
online games using net zero by the way
using net zero because again i didn't
have the money to pay yourself but we
figured out a way how to play online
gaming for free man so i was only paying
for my for my 56k modem i had a phone
line that i did i got from my room just
to play
fanny star online dude and i did it
through net zero and only had
45 minutes
to play
yeah and then no no not like that like
the
we figure out a way to hack it
play the game but every four to five
minutes it resets so i have to like in
the middle of a battle i'll get
disconnected
i'll reconnect again i'll go back like
it was very complicated again but you
know but anyways
just that like playing
nfl 2k for the first oh
shout out to visual concepts brother
yo it was insane choo choo rocket dude
it was it was dope and uh there was
other games too but yo those room
ready yeah yeah yeah so caliber
yeah it was though it was shenmue oh my
god he literally had the best launch
lineup of everything yeah
ever and that was the thing that
petermore mentioned something he said he
said
we had too many games yeah at launch and
that was their mistake because now
they're dry for months right
that's why the strategy what nintendo
did for the nintendo switch
every month
for the first year's launch they had an
exclusive yes you know what i'm saying
but imagine you throw everything that
you have
all the ammo and then you're like okay
now what now we're struggling like yo we
need more content and there's nothing we
have to wait for months
sega had a lot of mismanagement when it
came to a lot of different things the
head was in a proper space with a lot of
their consoles and like you said it was
a headways of time it fit because it
died prematurely the dreamcast did if it
was actually launched in a proper manner
with a little bit more funding to to go
up against uh playstation 2
i think it could have stuck around but
it lent itself yeah because i believe
that xbox is the spiritual successor to
what sega did because remember microsoft
had windows on and then peter moore
himself even said you know he took it
personally that sony killed his three
cats and he was like
because here's the thing
when sony ps2 released they had the dvd
so now you're getting the non-gamers
yeah and you get the gamers buying it
and they're like oh this is the cheapest
dvd player
facts and the best dvd facts good point
good point lord danny again thank you
brother for your time tremendous history
done legend it's an honor being here man
i know dude we could have been here for
under bro yeah
crazy stuff
yeah bro we go we definitely got to get
you back or at least when when things
get better in the world whether e3 or
whatever you know linking up doing this
in person because your history is truly
tremendous you are a part father in a
space you don't get your roses we going
to give them to you brother you know
thanks man you know what i mean you
blaze the trail so like yeah we want to
give you your outros and stuff like that
but attic hey brother let me give him
his outro yeah we don't even have 300
episodes man
[Music]
so i was having i had a lot of fun doing
this and originally i'm like oh maybe an
hour
i appreciate you brother brother
but i want to mention one thing because
i know somebody asked this multiple
times and i forgot to answer the
question but
he mentioned chip and zach and people do
not a lot of people the majority don't
know what chip zack are yeah they have a
show
that was created at that time when i
created my show was called gaming noise
okay and that was the first show in my
opinion that was like
professionally made special facts
segments you know because mine was
straight up like straight up hood like
yo
yeah we outside
because i see you on you got your
promoter vibe when you had the bike when
you was doing stuff yeah so i uh i i
still stay in touch with them
we talked i even actually got them in
also to cbs
um to to do the same exact thing so it
was drink champs and them at the same
time because i was like yo
a lot of people don't know about chip
and zac man and they're legends man they
also were part of up during that time of
of new shows man you know what i'm
saying
that's the thing yeah
in your eye and you want to make sure
that the world sees exactly what you see
in your eye yeah yeah yeah
yeah i just want to say that right oh
love brother so let's give all danny
flowers on his outro
yeah uh my brother i gotta tell you this
i've always from from the jump i'm like
danny's og like he's his gaming the
gaming stuff it goes without saying but
beyond that i i knew nothing right i
knew nothing i'm just like all right you
know we started this gaming stuff this
podcast is not fantastic
you never really know
until you hear it from the horse's mouth
right about the details of of what it
took you to get where you are and
especially when you talk about like this
the confluence of the games with the
hip-hop and all the other stuff you were
doing promoting
and just the grind bro like
i
i've never seen this level of sort of
passion and ingenuity from a kid that
starting from 12 13 years old figuring
out how can i turn this thing that i
love to do
into something that's beneficial to me
that i can live off of and to have that
sort of that industrial spirit and
everything that you do from when you're
young yeah and to continue to grind
because it's not easy when you get told
no yes it's not easy when you get told
no and
most people will just shut it down and
be like i'm going to just go the easy
route or the route that's safe yep or
have someone from pr snatch your tape
right now
that would demoralize a person yeah
so for you to keep grinding and pushing
and doing all the things you've done to
this point to get where you are man um
i'm glad you're finally getting your
flowers yes
it's a long time it should have happened
a long time a long time it really has
yeah but man to be i'm so happy that
you're finally on the show with us
happy for everything that's happening to
you congratulations on your engagement
congratulations on becoming part of g4
tv
bro scott skye's the limit brother
that's the limit brother it really is
like i'm not i did not think i would be
so moved by your story
thanks a lot man yeah i know there's a
lot of i appreciate that man so much i
know that a lot of people
are super curious about my story and
that there's dude there's tons of other
ones that i even did uh i did a
documentary a couple years ago uh it's
called gamertag greater podcast amazing
i
made that documentary for my community
it wasn't like for the public or
anything like that you know so
i
submit the i submitted the documentary
to multiple film festivals and it got
picked up a it got an awards like best
feature film and all that stuff man and
the thing that people don't know
i edit the whole thing wow to do imovie
yeah the reason why i did that through
imovie is to show people that it's not
about
the the big time software
the the expensive equipment it's about
the content i have an amazing story and
i want to inspire other people so i
posted it and submitted to all these
places and you know was the two two i
forgot to mention two of the highlights
and one of them was for this
was the dominican film festival one of
the biggest film festivals in new york
uh called me they wanted me to be part
of it and actually i met one of the kids
that uh he's an actor that he's in the
new um
uh doc docu series uh on netflix about
uh what's his name connolly from uh from
a football player
uh oh god kaepernick kaepernick
so he's the dominican too that kid uh so
i met him at the event you know saying
we were like in the red carpet and
everything and uh
and i took my mom in the red carpet you
know i took my mom to times square
brother when she saw the the billboard
i did that because
she helped me since day one she gave you
the inspiration i'm saying so at the
same time
you know i wanted to
submit to other places all the fields
festivals so if you guys want whoever's
watching this go to
story
dot gamertag radio.com that's
story.gimmertagrow.com and it's a 60
minute documentary and talking about
like how i met paris and this like yeah
it's bro i watched the whole thing
it's amazing it's it's lit it's really
and you've got live footage you've got
so much going on brother i got it i
don't normally would respect the super
chat because it was long but is gtr on
video if any plans to do video and
someone said they want to keep them for
the ride
we've been like we
do stuff like on twitch you know i do
streaming there and we do our live shows
there you know but
our our focus is it's always been audio
for me especially you know like it's
good to do video like there's certain uh
videos that i do put up online on
youtube and on twitter and stuff like
that you know but uh the bigger audience
that we have has always been audio no
doubt yeah yeah king give danny's
flowers before you get out of here man
well um
what what i see with danny danny
goes out of his way and he helps people
facts and um
that that that's the biggest thing
it's not about uh how can danny get a
bag
it's how danny can help everybody else
around them and you went back to the
dominican republic see um
my wife is dominican mm-hmm all right
and uh
some people might not know the culture
some people might think you know puerto
rico and the dominican republic is the
same it's not the same
um
it's it's it's a real third world
country
right so when you go back home and
you're bigging up your people and you're
telling them i can do this and this is
how
you're going right back to that space
where you was there and you were alone
and you didn't have any help there so
you don't want anyone to feel like you
so you're going out and you're helping
because you remember that space that
nothing in space that twenty dollars
that you had in your pocket is trying to
make it happen you always remember where
you come from
you're that kid from new york city
walking in times square with his mom's
looking up
at your face at a billboard full circle
brother full circle
you did a thousand
episodes man he did that like you are
the pod father like for real
talk right give it to him i really
respect that listen i i told you i'm
sitting here my wife texts me
she's like be hard to build it baby
real absolute brother there's a lot of
pride there
and i'm just grateful that i got a
chance to spend some time with you got a
chance to hear your story facts you got
a chance to understand who you were
because
sovereign's been talking about you
forever like you know you're gonna have
danny and we're gonna have danny on
we're gonna have danny on yeah okay okay
he's he paris friend all right paris is
cool yeah paris even gave it up paris
benton even we had parasol he bent the
needles brother yeah for sure to you
danny he's like i'm like oh this is
danny yeah
yeah now i know who danny is thank you
danny for blessing our day thank you
brother yo thanks so thank you for
inviting me man it was a lot of fun
thank you brother enjoy your day you
always welcome back in the round
oh my full addict my bad my bad
you were you know he went to you i went
[Laughter]
i've always said one thing you know
the passion man like
i i get tired of seeing you know it's
one thing on twitter that you know you
could i don't like this this concept
in the social media aspect where you
have to be neither left or right in
terms of you have to be completely on
everyone all the time or you have to be
completely positive all the time and i
like the people that sit in the middle
you can see the passion and that's why i
like about you it's like you know i've
always sensed fairness with you and
anything you've ever done well you know
that that's one of the reasons you you
you know hard work determination and
you've always had a fairness brand and
that's what i've always valued in terms
of your brand no i really do appreciate
you coming on man it's it was it was a
great interview no doubt yeah it was a
lot of fun my god this stuff i mentioned
i've never talked about probably
shout out to you shout out to paris he
said tell king to stop swelling danny's
head
your man should
[Laughter]
man put your hands together go talk paul
father enjoy your sunday brother and you
are welcome in the realm any time
brother yeah you're remember we got we
got we took way more time but he's not
all good so go hey make sure to check
out the launch of g4 man uh oh yeah
it's going to be
down brother yeah man there's gonna be a
lot to talk a lot to talk about november
15th is the 20th hour absolutely
absolutely have a good one brother hi
guys
thank you brother sorry if you want to
get this in the chat
yeah hold on i got them all let me run
it back a little bit so let's vamp for a
moment while running no doubt spending
the blocks off while you do that i'm
gonna run to the back you run about i'll
do the i'll do the poll i'll do the poll
while you're doing all that and i'm
saying again salute everybody that
pulled up this is it's a lot of fun you
know obviously a little much longer
interview but danny's a legend and when
he has time you got to take it you know
so yeah that's one of those things so i
will uh get into the poll last week's
poll results are in the people have
spoken with their recent announcement of
sony first party titles like god of war
coming to pc do you think that sets the
stage for more of these titles to come
day and date on pc the winner of the
poll kind of competitive 54 of the vote
was yes sony knows first party games on
pc will not damage their brand these
exclusives will eventually come day and
date only a matter of time then we got
coming in at second at 37 percent of the
vote was the messy lords i don't care
what happens we just here to salute
whatever worldwide gym does for the
company
in the last place and only eight percent
of the vote was no so he still values
their first party and will only get them
on pc after a year or two with ps5 sales
begin to slow down shoot to all around
lords with a realm who voted this uh so
i'll be attic what do you think man you
think they got it right that they think
it's coming day and date
oh yeah it's definitely coming day and
day whoever don't see that you're not
paying attention yeah i'm glad to see
that the poll is showing reason people
are being reasonable i'm shocked i was
shocked that they was gonna fight this
too
i do
have some stuff to talk about uh one is
uh i don't king to briefly talked about
it earlier we did do the chivalry to uh
live stream for the milestone thing that
we usually do
because you know you guys support us in
a lot of different ways uh especially
patreon and and members we do want to
give back to you guys in terms of that
uh so we did achieve that so pretty
oh my god
really oh okay we really let me finish
this before he starts his stuff i guess
we're doing the sony topic next day
let me just minimize the screen yes
continue
son so we need
uh we did have a new member so we need
uh our next goal is going to be 14 new
members or patreon uh then we'll stream
another game i saw you guys liking you
know
chivalry too
there's a there's a a bunch of different
games up for grabs that you guys can
pick uh you know we we do have a few
that we have uh in thought process what
i want you guys to do is in the comments
section and in the chat put a game that
you would like us for to stream right
right i'm kind of curious on that uh i
personally think it would be funny if we
played the the the mario party superstar
because whatever that that that that
game can be very messy like i can't
especially those mini games
no it's a switch game
he said
so wait how many do we need we just need
one copy of that right
no you need four we need four yeah
no no
because because all four of us are gonna
have to have that
dodotaku says doki doki literature club
anybody who's played that game wow
people keep telling me to play that i
don't
i see
i don't know i feel like that's a game i
shouldn't play
no don't don't play it
no doubt no doubt so we're good at it
because we got to get these so so that's
pretty much it so i will put a poll
after i read a couple of them i'll put a
poll in there and you know kind of get a
gauge of interest in what you guys want
to see uh so uh we are not playing sing
star uh just pointing that out right now
key come on all right look we got to get
these chats going ready yeah let's go
we got mr wolfe with the four pound and
49 pence super chat sega doing cash
changed my gaming life no sega dreamcast
no xbox for me never looked back after
that that is very kind of real kind of
real
then we got the dutch rudder 81 with the
ten dollar speech
playstation found my old psn name
offensive [ __ ] 8127 and banned me
until i changed it i don't know what's
defensive about that apparently the
dutch rudder 81 is appropriate google
apparently felt the same way so here's
the new name love the show thank you
brother absolutely shout out to your new
name the dutch rudder so once again
we got the dutch rudder 81 once again
five dollars for chat hola miami salute
from an old resident of the nine five
four uh not too crazy got too crazy down
there so i had to take my mexican self
to boston i love your work mad at that i
ain't mad at that mm-hmm
and then we got it
time to get out of it yes
and we got raiden blade two pound super
chat hello lords on this great day
welcome mr pena yes
no doubt and we got brett bingham five
dollar super chat forza horizon 5 early
access is this week when people ask when
i'm playing thursday i reply like mac
from super troopers
[Laughter]
then we got michael patton two dollars
super chat og xbox forever bless the
gamers i was 20 years old
yes sir yes sir
raiden blade two pound super chat again
going to say this playstation pc king
said it last playstation console
then we got burp bingham again five
dollar super chat so forza horizon 5
premium edition early access is supposed
to start on november 5th according to
the store the game releases on november
4th this should be fixed shaking my head
they will probably fix that
um
brayden blade again five pound super
chat also playstation trying to upstage
halo with horizon forbidden west but my
question is
why did they use the same stage replace
the humans with raptors and same stage
every time
every time thank you i guess david jaffe
pointed this out
then we have mick fury
super chat
yeah dello mio danny and to my guys
happy sunday good to see y'all in good
health i wish i could stay but these
fools need me and jesus and need me and
jesus
okay special shout out to king for that
awesome dark side statue oh
yeah yeah yeah no doubt no doubt i got
raiden blades on fire today raiden blade
five pound super chat mr pena and the
lords i'm so jealous that you all got to
experience e3 i was looking forward to
traveling to the states with my
daughters but covet attacks yeah
hopefully that will change soon
then we got raiden blade again two pound
super chat i would love to see you all
there in the future absolutely
absolutely absolutely
raiden blade again two pounds of chat uh
one the true grinders of podcasting mr
pena history yes yes
a lot of words that describe him bro we
got so many exclusives from him wow that
was crazy yeah
cool raiden blade again too bouncing
with your iop thank you for the great
guests you always deliver thank you
brother
raiden blade again two pound super chat
it costs nothing to treat others with
respect absolutely a lot of the stuff
that happens when you podcast and you
talk talk to people it's just common
sense
just be good
uh radem blade five pound super chat
again is jamaican jim ryan making
another appearance to cover his
playstation pc to explain to his
followers that this might be or could be
their last console the playstation
the writings
then we have amrit with the 500 rupee
super chat can't wait for for caribbean
jim's worldwide views on the beauty that
was last week's state of play
shout out to raiden blade again uh lord
bronze welcome to the brown a member for
nine months actually yeah so shout out
to him you know i'm home relaxing with
the lords commenting in chat lords you
inspired me to want to do this scene the
hard grind i have more respect oh salute
thank you thank you brother thank you
then we got reggie mobile 9 5 super chat
man this interview was cold shout out to
og danny pena and the dopest most
underrated part in the realm the iron
lords bless your brothers
thank you
brett bingham 5 super chat is jim
jamaican dance moves ryan going to play
forza horizon 5.
who knows what could happen today
raider blade once again two pound super
chat i'm rewatching this tomorrow work
mg pure gold no doubt salute thank you
sir reggie mobile nine two dollars with
a chat final fantasy three yes that's
one of my favorite games of all time no
doubt okay it's my easy with the five
dollar super chat i need at least two
minutes of jim jamaican dance moves ryan
on this show i hope the wig is not far
from lord king anyway awesome
entertaining podcast i don't know what
you're talking about with this wig yeah
i don't know
he was here i don't know what y'all
talking about
we're very lucky to get him to make an
appearance cameo every now and then
exactly
i thought jim was showing up when that
camera turned back on
well i think you know i don't think it's
a segment because we have to get an xbox
topic yeah
then we got rainer blade once again to
pop super chat this is my dude dreamcast
fantasy star online first yeah
that was that was a special moment yes
sir and we got michael patton five
dollar super chat final fantasy v
introduced the job system it released
later thank you yeah it released later
than six materia system any magic for
any character that was it yeah
you can put like you could you could mix
and match yeah it didn't matter um final
fantasy 6 is my favorite as well
the one that introduced the job system
and that was my favorite okay yeah yeah
then we got right in the 81 had the job
system they were referring to like
breaking down the job breaking it down
yeah yeah
yeah
so you could put it on to any character
no predetermined stuff yeah raiden blade
two pound super chat look at the moment
uh look at the moment tomb raider was
stolen from sega by sony exactly yes
there's been a lot of misinformation
going on around around the anniversary
of tomb raider it came out on the saturn
first yes yes and it looked
[Laughter]
is gtr on video if not any plans to do
video yet we talked about that yeah we
talked about it probably not
yeah you gotta keep it audio
michael patton two dollars of a chat
apparently final fantasy three as well
yes
then we got raiden blade two pound super
chat once again i would like him to
stick around for the rest of the podcast
he stayed he's supposed to give us yeah
he's supposed to give us that and he
gave us two out bro he kept going we
don't need this to sully his uh his gps
cause he's about to get messy there we
go always cola five dollar super chat
congrats to danny and all the success on
your journey wish you much more a
success to come
by
more afraid a great interview no doubt
hello salute and we got split
splendiferous two dollar super chat
appreciate everything you've done home
skillet painia no doubt
legend
is for sure uh crazy og so hold on let
me roll back because we got a few more
why are you doing that um shout out to
anonymous he just got that uh he got the
he got the glass though he got the drink
glass joint with the iop on it put your
name in man put a shout out when you're
getting the merch i said i'm low again
well you say you no you're good okay
yeah you're good yeah you ready yeah i'm
ready all right heart get chani member
for five months no doubt pony vision
blinds play season fanboys from seeing
good games on other platforms they see
halo with terrible graphics don't care
about gameplay great hearing danny's
story salute to the lords on halloween
as well sir
[Music]
and we got fat boy horror five pounds
danny's an awesome interview but that's
saturn slander man
yeah he's exactly bro yeah favorite
heart was bad you you were so yeah i saw
that i said they like daddy at that
moment
[Music]
then we have danger uxo twenty dollars
if we chat when we when will we see phil
on hey man hey man
look we we we we we'll work on that
eventually man right now let's just
focus on getting past this pog
[Laughter]
and we got spartan go 17 two pound super
chat robot ryan paddling to bermuda with
no games wow
then we have the games gaming forte five
dollar super chat great guests and show
lords keep bringing the community
amazing content at least you understand
getting paid on youtube then sitting in
spaces for 16.
forte on to something you know what i'm
saying a lot of gems by danny today yes
sir and we have ryan ginther two dollar
super chat
hashtag playstation pc keep up the great
work
spaces isn't a bad thing it's when it's
used for bad purposes it's okay yeah i
mean it is what it is you know but we're
trying to get this money let's go then
we got suicide kings two dollars thank
god i didn't miss the messiness today
absolute salute suicide with the devil
who's that how to get to gaby forte been
a member for nearly two years wow
brother blessing two-year hype right
around the corner love you guys and as
always hey
[Laughter]
all right so let's get into it y'all um
just want to be quick um hello infinite
campaign
trailer interesting got the uh
notification on a sunday night then uh
monday morning was it 9 am eastern big
news on the monday
yeah it dropped out man so we didn't get
a chance to talk about it in the realm
let's start with attic man we you won't
you said you hit me like huh
just let you know i bought the sports
ball drink i'm like what you know so
what's going on man tell me how you felt
about that infinite sir
i i like what i saw on it i i thought
the information they showed
was good um i did see people asking for
more like i'm kind of curious on what
more could they have showed like did
they just want to see the game like all
the cut scenes like
like i felt like they showed the
mechanics they showed a good amount of
what you're gonna do in the game they
showed the amount of how you're gonna
play the game uh they introduce more
aspects you know they it looks like
a little bit of exploration inspired by
uh some of the ubisoft games which isn't
necessarily a bad thing
just because ubisoft's games are getting
a little bit you know tiring to a lot of
different people you know maybe not
people like such as myself doesn't mean
everyone yeah is getting to that point
you know i i feel like
that outpost doesn't necessarily mean
that it's going to be
ubisoftified but i definitely understand
people's concern
yeah i definitely understand the uh the
concerns with that i i thought i
honestly think that
this has gave them
enough
power
to shut my mouth okay okay that's big
for you i don't i don't think i need to
see any more halo uh infinite i think
i've seen enough okay uh it's it's
definitely looking like it's going to be
a solid experience definitely look out
for the review on uh
i will be reviewing um
halo infinite on the iop channel the
channel you're currently watching this
podcast on uh so definitely look out for
that i i honestly feel i feel real
confident like i don't know why like
i think we'll see something else on halo
for some reason i feel like we're going
to see something else on halloween i
don't know if it's like the anniversary
they might hit us with another one
but i do think we might see like a
straight cgi story trailer okay okay you
know what i'm saying i think this they
show you the overview how you're going
to play the game what the objective
they're going to play the game and the
next one they hit you with that this is
the narrative and this is what's going
to be happening okay uh
hey look at it
good good way to come out swinging it
related did you see did you see the the
other trailer with the brute talking
while they're building chief you saw
that one right
yeah but they're pretty much
that was kind of a rehash of like what
they did before yeah
and you know what's crazy i'm seeing
people in the community i ain't gonna
say no names
here we go
they they're seeing they're they're
showing
that individual brute that's on there
and they're like oh man atriox this
atriox that is
supposedly dead here right supposedly no
he's not dead but he it's interesting
that he's not been shown
yeah kind of makes me think he is dead
really because who
he's going to become the new
uh
flood greymon
i think the flood might have killed him
and took over his body because like look
that's that's a stretch it's probably
okay this is a long theory okay but that
that's that's a pretty stretch theory
but to me aatrox is a very dominant
person yeah he's not gonna let this
other person speak for him all this time
you know what i'm saying like
like
if
they said what the bandits took out
all humanity in like six months yeah
yeah so where is he did he just go like
what if it's like change whatever it's
like chain of command he got just a
little general zone you know i'm saying
he up to you on top on the throat my
point is is
why didn't i see this man's in halo wars
2
like this is supposed to be his mentor
everyone why haven't i seen this dude
why is it this dude is act like
he doesn't really refer to atriox as is
even a library but what if they just
kind of saving it for narrative you know
like let's be real they ain't giving us
a lot of story beats for the mo they
being very close to vests on a lot of
still a lot of stuff they give this
piece here piece there but not really
what if they save him for like yo real
late in the campaign you know what i'm
saying to me if because this is how i
feel like this is going to go apparently
someone bought a snapback yeah they buy
mad stuff right now i got you i got you
all right so this is how
my thing i feel like halo infinite is
going to go into
the direction where every
six months to a year they're going to
add a new art kind of like how they do
anime okay where you know you got the
you got certain arcs and anime of
certain villains right i think that's
what they're going to do with halo but
kind of like how they do destiny where
it's like look this coming up february
is the sabbath
okay
you're going to be told on september
okay the way it's looking like like the
original destiny 2 the the coming out
vanilla destiny 2 was the red the red
wall hold on hold on hold on the chat is
checking us all right two things alvin
says atriox is stuck on the installation
eshroom whatever that dude name might be
trying to free him and then as though
said atriox appears as a hologram in the
campaign trailer behind the brute that
runs to chief in the trailer that's what
i'm saying so they say he allowed
at the end of the day just because he's
a hologram doesn't mean he's around okay
like that could that could be a variety
to me
if he's if he is trapped somewhere how
is the ban is someone that made the
humanity that beat the covenant fall in
four months when the covenant fought
them for years and couldn't win how can
he be stuck somewhere and the banish
can't get to it
that don't make sense to me like to me
look the flood thing is complete stretch
that's made like like a like something
that i would want to happen but to me
it's weird he still hasn't been part of
any marketing room gotcha
it's it's weird that the people that was
shown in halo wars 2 the brothers
the the shipmaster i believe yeah i
remember you might be dead they're none
of them are in any of these trailers
right none of the basically they're halo
wars 2 people yeah i got you i got you
so explain to me how these iconic people
in halo wars 2 that is really like like
the core people that halo wars 2 made
you believe was that it's inner circle i
haven't seen it i got you but my thing
is i'm giving you some my question is do
you think they would really kill them
off screen though that would be kind of
whack like yeah
but the thing is is we don't know what
happens at the beginning of the game
either we don't know what ha like
because uh everything we've seen is
after the game starts they've showed you
unseen after the game sorry and the duke
they do just to me he's probably alive i
just find it interesting that we still
haven't seen atrion i'll get you like
atrialx was built to be such a
powerhouse he took on three spartans
yeah that's what you sold me he was
roughing them spawn
and we haven't seen one marketing
campaign with this dude what could have
been the dude that knocked uh
[Laughter]
my thing is like back to what i was
saying like i think it's going to be
released in segments released
in arcs and i think the vanilla yeah
infinite it's not gonna oh i see where
you're going that's where you going
right to me if it's going to be the
banished unless atrialx just pops in in
the middle of the game out of nowhere
which is a possibility you know maybe
he's to to me who else could they be
conquering neil cognito says esheram i'm
butchering his name if i'm sorry i'm not
a pronouncer so what is it
as estheram esherum is one of the four
hands of atriox he was sent to zeta halo
a waiting on aatrox but ended up in a
war with the unc
yeah maybe they setting it up hey maybe
they setting up but i feel like
i mean it would be cool
all right
to me oh the lady the lady that knocked
him
no i don't want to know no he wouldn't
know how chief got woke up what happened
well i gotta be knocked out that's how
he found out he was on the ring and they
blew the ring up they blew the ring up
i don't know man i think the story gonna
go different i think atriox knocked them
smooth
knocked them into the end
well i gotta be knocked about it so this
is the revenge just the payback story
he was stressed
at the end of the day you know i i
definitely want i definitely want to be
wrong i don't necessarily think he's
dead
i'm just throwing out the question why
haven't we seen him this is the most
daunting
to come out right now in halo history
this is the most dominant person they've
ever had
spoilers yeah
all the stories from the rip like i
agree
i'm just saying from from from an aspect
to someone that played halo wars 2 right
where they put all that marketing around
where they and they they're putting all
the work around but but they're putting
all the marketing around the banished
and astrox is the band but my thing is
if you give a shocks to the people now
you
sorry for graphic language you blew your
like you don't say like
you got to build this thing up you talk
about a 10 year
yeah but my thing is you give him now we
show they do what you want they show h
whatever whatever then you go
yeah but if you go beat up atriox now
like that's deflating like you got to
build this thing up they got a lot of
game
but it's i guess maybe it's coming from
the person that play halo wars yeah you
did i'm not saying you did no no no no
it's you're right they did such a good
job of building on screen i know and
then i'm just like i don't like this
random loser that
you're like you're like banished b from
apartment 2c talking i don't like this
banished
is you know what they washer what it is
i think they're doing the game of death
thing where you have to build up you got
to make your way to the boss right
that's what i'm saying he got to fight
the subway he went halo back to chief
and go to the chief get to fight the
master first
the biggest thing about what i saw on
the story you know i'm on the podcast
shut my door go yeah you know the
biggest question i have shout out to
zach always interrupted
who is the person that is that through
chief that's the biggest who the person
that that stuff no you talk about the
other chick that one that stuff said she
said that you're not the future yeah
yeah i'm talking about the one that was
like the one that i am not like that
called the four runners pretty much
called them liars or whatever right
and she she she disappeared teleported
behind him and threw him through two
walls
[Music]
i'm interested if that assassin that
kills spartans is one individual or is
that a group yeah right that's gonna be
fired i'm doing it
imagine like the dude
imagine walking around the map and you
cut and you just randomly like two or
three of them just randomly pop out of
nowhere that's what i like dual sabers
like i like the lore they're building up
i like what they're doing i have a lot
more faith in 343 than i did a year ago
they were a little bit man i was getting
a little bit down on 343
but i like what they've done of like the
build up with the the multiplayer of
like the builder with the on the single
player i like the lord how they're
building great opportunity mm-hmm yeah
it's called atriox no we're not going
in the chat are saying it is a it is a
uh a group so that's i don't know if
they've come officially and said that
but i was curious if they're
legitimately training people to kill
sparta
somebody somebody in the chat saying
that the the the the chick that knocks
him out is the didact's wife
um
shut up so we gotta get some of it man
cause we gotta we gotta do this so
yeah what you thought on the other
campaign trailer
yeah everything that i saw was
made me breathe aside really i was like
oh it looks it looks like halo it looks
like halo it looks like i said for me
halo is
the sandbox and what you could do with
those physics in any given point in time
and
to making the game that semi-open world
thing when you're going from like
installment to installment kind of
taking out a boss in each one you can
approach them stealthily if you want to
although although you know chief showed
that he didn't want to do that
but it did i saw that i'm like oh far
cry it feels like far cry they're giving
you the option to approach these any
which way you can and again when it
comes to halo
when you implement all those physics and
a lot of crazy things can happen
and to me that aspect of the gameplay
the upgrade stuff all that stuff seems
great and it feels like a natural
evolution what halo 3 was right right it
really does feel like it's that
oh you're not about that okay yeah they
saying that they saying king audio low
because i mean he must be really far
from his bike and so well okay okay they
just they just
now before you keep leaning back yeah
you got to remember when you lean back
on that mic it go away but they love
what they they what you would say but
continues off so all of that
let me address this this this super chat
addict wants dados defeated
[Applause]
i'm just curious why he hasn't been in
any marketing but that's all like
and i know
you probably didn't play halo wars 2 but
this man was front and center throughout
all of
yeah so they know who knocked
[Laughter]
i gotta go jump ahead with slow he said
to us
who slumped the chief find out that
somebody has to
you're trying to play you know what
king's trying to do like the last season
of power or every episode yeah like
reach out other who killed gold
yeah i want to know who slumped chief
[Laughter]
yo who dead armed chief like
that dude right there yeah dead arm
chief like
gotta float this space continues on
so yeah so like everything i saw in
terms of the gameplay i liked as an
evident as an evolution of what halo was
going to be right they already told us
to be open world so we knew it was going
to be somewhat different now the only
thing that i haven't seen yet again and
is to did showed a little bit of an
overview of the gameplay is that halo is
still made up of big sort of
water cooler moments yeah even within
all the stuff you can do in the sandbox
and
because the world is more open
it i wonder if
it it lends itself to that those sort of
moments just because the world is more
open meaning meaning
and i hope it's not true there's less
scripted moments within the world so
there could be moments that things sort
of appear serious possibility yeah there
could be moments that things sort of
appear sort of samey because of the
nature of the open world as opposed to a
game that's fully scripted it has like
the big scarab moments and stuff like
that so my only sort of concern is that
because of the way the game is set up
now
we will we won't see that type of stuff
or we'll see less of it because again a
halo campaign
has the sandbox part and it also has the
parts that are that are epic and right
and sort of big he wasn't feeling like
when you know he's getting the one on
one he's getting it in with the brew or
the right dude came down and elevated
with the seminar cinematic and weapon
was like yo that might be a phrase right
now that's trouble i'm not so worried
about it in terms of inside of
installations and smaller spaces yeah
i'm more worried about it in terms of
out in the open world like like i said
like the big scarab moment or the big
sort of big team battle moments that you
see in multiplayer but also there are
moments during a single player where
that sort of stuff happens right and it
just i just want to know that they're
able to do that within the confines of
this semi-open world you know what i
mean
beyond that question for you saul
are are you going to pick the are you
going to play this of course he plays
everything
but is is is it more halo
oh
he covered for you
oh that wasn't done
check this out
you're gonna have to check yourself out
[Applause]
first of all he's over here talking
smack about a game he doesn't care about
that much i don't know why you've been
bringing it
secondly
how much of a jump has there been from
let's say gears one to five in terms of
core mechanics right
you're now you're comparing it to a halo
this open world i'm sorry was there any
other halo's open world before there was
a gears 5's open world
yo bro do not even tell me about getting
live open world
instead of walking down a corridor you
can go to the door to the left or door
to the right that's their open world get
out of here
you got to stop against the ropes
like you're just getting a warhog and
drive to a base to a baseball bat
but that's not borrow halo attic that's
what you're trying to say
and that game is 20 years old
it's okay they redo halo as long as just
[Music]
and then that game is 20 years old right
so let's say let's say you talk about
the last halo halo 5
nothing like this
so they changed it
here's four
they went back to the old halo they made
halo more like halo the old halo i don't
know
upwards and made gears more unique by
giving it an open world aspect and they
went back with him
and you're going to look at me you're
going to look me in the face and tell me
that that open world was it it was late
it was mad exploration
all right we're going to put time we're
going to put time cause y'all messy
y'all man this is gonna go on for let's
go go for enough hours this is what
happens when addict wants to argue for
sake of arguing and he doesn't have a
leg to stand on it
here we go
anyway
moving on this is an attic world
argument
i know attic do it though he'd be a mess
i know what he's doing
but
it ain't sticking
anyway so overall
anyway so overall though you're good
just some slight concerns as far as the
the storytelling as far as those moments
in this type of um open world yeah
exactly kind of thing no doubt no
so i don't really again i think they
should be able to do it but again in
open world when you look at the open
world you start looking at things that
start looking the same like the
installation start looking the same
right right right
and like but my thing is also biome
diversity i want to see
like are we gonna get different areas
you know what i'm saying whether it be
snow desert kind of thing what happened
okay
the podcast froze
you froze oh i'm still frozen we're good
now okay we're back okay okay we're back
so anyway so that was it so you all
right king what's up man besides the
chief slumping what would you like to
slump all right besides the fact that
who knocked out the chief um
doesn't it look like just cause too
oh
just cause
just closed
i said
um it has little areas that you go to
you got to take down these facilities
and knock out these people over here in
this corner with the chief when he
jumped off the roof like does he gonna
get a wingsuit next
thing from place to place
um
the game looks not king is bottom i
think it's me with the connection
because i it's yeah i see that yeah it's
the connected unstable connection yeah
it might be my network today sorry y'all
but we'll see what it is
it's back now yeah so
okay yeah we're good yeah yeah yeah
we're good right now um
it looks fantastic
it just goes back to my theory they
didn't need it last year and they could
have put it back in the cooker and let
it cook more yeah yeah um i went and
watched the old stream from it and uh
compared it to the the new stream they
added more visual effects to certain
stuff and it looks more fleshed out they
made sure that they didn't do certain
things to
uh to mask and they didn't want to
repeat of craig face
and all this other stuff
i don't i don't want to know nothing
about the story okay actually to be
honest with you i don't want to see any
more stuff i don't want to hear nobody
talking i already saw do the multiplayer
stuff do all that stuff i'm pretty sure
i'm gonna be good with every campaign
i've been great with every campaign
that's come out with uh for halo
even the one where um
what what was the guy and you you um you
he took over statement arbiter oh okay
yeah oh yeah that was that was my
biggest problem with that one that you
had to be the arbiter but again
it looks like you know halo i get the
chance to play with master chief again
pause
and
we get to find out who's slump chief
that's that's that's all that is that's
all it is if you're looking at it right
and
everybody's laughing like oh king is
bugging out
no that dude came down the elevator and
she was like no that might be a friend
he like nah that's not a friendly right
dude come rushing out you know and i
don't know man
he could have slumped him then
that knocked him through the wall yeah
in the beginning could be h we don't
know what point is the slumping and he
floating in space uh-huh figure out who
slumped chief and i think that should be
going forward we gotta find out who laid
out the chief who got his flow he's done
feet up under the ropes i need to find
that but other than that it looked
fantastic guys
what i expected it looked like what i
expected no doubt no doubt yeah chad
thanks for the um thing on um the volume
stuff i'm looking at it right now i
think what happened is the ovs stream is
taking your settings attic from last
thing and it had the mic volume high and
i'm coming higher than you guys and i
think that's what it was they were
because they were like attic and kingdom
sounds low i think what it is it was my
individual so i'm looking at it now so
apology shot dick that was on me and obs
just wilding because we did multiple
streams but anyway look i'll jump in yo
it look it look good they look good um
yeah the the sandbox the ai potential
looks crazy you know and i'm a guy that
really i got a lot of open world fatigue
and i i got like concerns on it at first
but then when i see the sandbox and all
the cool things you could do in the
grapple hook and all of that like
man
i'm super excited the silly thing we
said it on stream addict was um the the
halo 5 when i saw the halo 5 thruster
back with the
like a customizable master chief is fire
to me you know i'm saying i love that
because to me he's a sport like he's
supposed to be able to personally i've
never
i've never
liked the idea
to make him move like a tank uh like
because he he suppose he he's heavy but
he's supposed to be mobile like that's
the whole reason they were designed yeah
they're not supposed to move like
they're a tank yeah and the thing that i
like that they put out the the blog
posts and stuff is that one thing they
know for is that ai like they've got the
best enemy ai going and the fact that
now the enemies they pick up the heavy
weapons on the ground now they chuck
stuff at you you can't use the grappling
hook on everybody you could do it on the
brutes but you try to do that on a
hunter it bounced off so like everyone's
starting to get their little properties
and stuff including chief with his joint
but not it looked good man i mean my
like i said the only thing upgrades oh
yeah
that looks nice yeah i like what they're
going with it man they they showed out i
remember the rpg upgrades from halo 1. i
remember that
they let them
[Laughter]
so we're gonna leave it we're gonna
leave it we're gonna leave it that was a
good fireback song cause he had you
against the rope before but that was a
good comeback
that's a good stuff
so
anyway
yeah man it was it was it was it was
good man i'm super excited for the
multiplayer i mean this campaign team
needed that good win for the team people
excited and my last thing is i like
the cinematic confrontation like king
was talking about the chick that came up
stuff that was like yo you ain't the
future you know i'm saying like yeah
like i like those cinematic things and
they look like they they're including it
in between the open world stuff and to
solve concern the biggest thing i just
want is the lord yes be do the lord
through the law and i'm good right so
yeah i'm good to go but that that's what
i got so we are good we are moving on
next topic but uh sorry some chance
between them did we miss anything oh
king just like went off camera so it's
about to get down
yeah it's about to go down
he's going upstairs and getting jim man
jen's upstairs in king's house right now
he's got to go and get him
no no look all i'm saying is you never
see king and jim ryan in the same room
i hereby ban all halo infinite slander
the multiplayer looks fire the campaign
looks far the corporate affordable
things look forward to bring on december
8th yes sir yes sir raiden blade two
power super chat imagine a 20 minute
recap before infinite starts
it could be yeah
brett bring them five dollars which i
think they're bringing in a track later
as the story revolves over the game's
life yeah
then we got raiden blade two pound super
chat a big boss don't need to talk until
he needs to yeah
that was a minion though that was a
minion
lord rufus five power super chat a book
writer straight up tells you i'm not
saying anymore you need to read the book
halo story dev should now say you need
to play the game
there we go brett bingham again five
thousand a lot of the unsc and former
covenant and banished forces are trapped
because of what cortana did leading the
ai revolution
no doubt
great in blade five pounds
uh no one knew of thanos until the
avengers assembled wait and see what
happens it's going to be a great journey
for us gamers no doubt yeah i think
but we know atrials
yeah i think they're going to build to
him i think it's going to be one of the
moments
it'd be like end of season one or
whatever the case might be yeah i could
see that um
brett bingham two dollars with a chat
king thinks halo infinite is another
rocky movie
okay
that we have carlos alvarado two dollar
super chat ao aoe4 breaking records for
our uh
forza horizon five this friday and halo
and we're about to talk about that yes
sir talk about these studios mm-hmm then
we got done otaku two dollar super chat
they confirmed that they are spartan
killers so we have special bandits that
are that's what i'm talking about yeah
it's being hunted so that's that's i
need them in danger they're always
beating everybody
probably not
so we got stitch popped on the super
chat okay we make caribbean jim a
patreon tier so that he makes an
appearance at least once a month hey
great show
we'll do it
now just waiting for the messy talk and
don't worry it's is it right around the
corner it's kevin
then we got alvin five dollars super
chat atria got them ernie shavers
lunch box
carlos alvarado two dollars super chat
love seeing the excitement behind xbox's
holiday yeah there's a lot of xbox
talking
on that place
what else we got then we got flame five
dollars we chat i'm glad everyone is at
least interested in halo but y'all can
have that until i can run around as
chief with my chief vets
we got brett bingham two dollars of
attack the new ai so who slumped you
chief
chief
343 is halo is fire now we need some
storytelling yes sir yes yes yes
whatever uh flame five dollars which i
can't wait to hear the pilots say chief
there's a settlement that needs our help
here let me mark it on your map for you
we got king one supreme sob with the
disrespect gears one and five are
different games gears five has stealth
melee combat and three player co-work
listen man i just i just want that
let's leave it cuz that's gonna be
another two hours continue
look i don't have to do anything the
chat's doing those are the super chats
we good hold up everybody something else
so we're gonna join the room too
um
we got mr irishman member for four
months time on the gears time on the
gift land i would like to remind some
folks at invented horde mode each game
has its own experimental game mode eg
escape beast mode yeah that's fine
whatever
this is solving the word you said we're
skipping super chats what do you mean
forte did you guys ever re-forte super
chat what's fuente's last super chat
yeah we still don't know
what the darkness is in destiny we're
about oh yeah yeah that's right yeah i
missed that one and the one above it
laurdinator yeah let's get him
okay so we have lord david five dollar
super chat
ah okay
so
you're gonna just read it just read it
just read it
yes
we still don't know who or what the
darkness is in destiny we knew about
sabathune for years and they finally
revealed her face
give it time
yes please okay you got read the one
above it
lord inator hold on a second we got lord
nader five dollars but addict want
thanos defeated on the first event
they will leave atriox for later because
he is the badass yes yes yes
i'm not i kind of agree with you
hold on where's flame flames i'm glad
everyone at least is interested in halo
but y'all can oh yeah yeah we did that
we did that yeah i read that oh we all
go
i think we're caught up all right cool i
want to get dark schneider salute to him
he got that stainless water bottle he
says i love this [ __ ] people are buying
stuff every show yeah man he got two of
those he got two water bottles that he
got that science back he got that ilp
snap no doubt loaded show solutions no
just in case you i don't see it there's
me we got a nice little uh backpack now
that i opened the logo go get that we
got stuff going on so look we got to set
it up someone buys that backpack that's
when jim shows up
so look we're gonna set it up transition
into this topic um yeah man sony funds
playstation pc brand for the future
ports uh shout out to what happened
let me just get this super chat before
kim goes on king so we gotta find all
these from josh mccaffrey or mccarthy i
don't know
lord addicts wants atriox right away
someone needs to tell him
what happened
to dak when he called out the empire
i don't even know what you're referring
to i don't know what that game is what
that movie is uh so you missed me with
that one right over my head does anyone
know what he's talking about dakin when
he called out the empire yeah put that
in the comment section george because
i'm curious yeah anyway
so yeah hold on i got to set it up
before if you do this so um yeah like i
said so uh shout out to windows central
shout out to sam tolbert the legend over
there salute um yeah man he pretty much
had the article out there sony funds uh
playstation pc brand for future ports
playstation games on pc won't be
published under the mobile division
anymore and basically he says what you
need to know sony's beginning to port
some of its existing ps4 catalog of
games to pc apparently these titles were
published on steam under the playstation
mobile division that's no longer and
then they recently founded a playstation
pc llc brand which seemed kicking stupid
which seems to be the publisher for
future ports we know god of war 2018 is
set to release and then he just said in
his arm article he said sony's been uh
more willingness to bring his pc games
to pc over the last couple of years with
helmand hermann holtz indicating that
ps4 ps4 games come to pc somewhere after
launch and then sony recently also
recently acquired nexus a dutch team
with experienced supporting games pc
that's your heart sony that's
seeing something that slowly interactive
ceo entertainment ceo jim ryan says will
aid in bringing to pc so again this
continues to set twitter ablaze as far
as somebody said jim
somebody said
what's going on people listen welcome
jim welcome
thank you before get your ginger beer
ready
everything is going according to plan
man
my boat is coming
me and gabe will be arming on with steam
deck
the playstation games look fabulous man
i must say
nexus is doing an extraordinary job
you're doing such a good job we farmed
out
god of war
we didn't even do that in-house
we have enough developers out here
willing to point our games over it's
such a rapid pace logic launcher making
you right um i wanted to ask you now
that you you know you're very aggressive
i feel like what would the captain know
we understand that yes you are the
candidate but my question is you know
to me it just seems a more flagrant
approach before you seem very subtle
with how you were doing things but now
you've formed an elephant man but what i
said rip it off
i'm not dance moves no more man fair
enough i miss the worldwide
but why form an llc bread it's almost
like a record label for playstation
ports everything has to be above board
man
i don't need the fed to come kicking me
down my door you're taking my boat back
listen
everything above board you want to look
at the books check it out it's an llc
man it's playstation pc llc
this is where we act with it man i'm not
playing with these guys no more uh-huh
it's coming dude you're running from me
wow yeah yeah so so i got a question for
you uh
worldwide jim ryan man i've always
wondered this but you know we've never
we never had the honor of talking to you
so i'm kind of curious what what
happened between you and sean late what
happened with all that with that sean
was not complicit man
he was not down for what we were talking
about i told him
i want to go worldwide i want to go
bigger i want to go better i want to go
day and date sean said no
no man
you gotta stay in your little wall
garden what the hell is this wall garden
i don't want no wall garden
i want everybody to have a chance to
play the playstation iep
[Music]
they are looking for me
you know i got i got emailed yesterday
man gabe told me he said hey hey hey
hey i said excuse me gabe what happened
he said hey just the email hey
hey hey so uh what do you say there's
been something that's been a little
criticism about uh how the playstation
games look on the steam deck uh have you
talked to gabe about you know optimizing
the game what the hell are you talking
about
what are you talking about
they're ready for it they're eager what
do you mean something look wrong they
said they were running at 500 people
with the eyes
[Laughter]
we're sending out a patch later
hey
if the nintendo switch can get away with
480i
so you're coming for that switchback now
we are out here for them
so it's a quick question
looks better than whatever they got over
there it doesn't matter listen i want
everybody in january to help me get this
boat
okay i already put the down payment down
so please
hold up hold up
look look dad's move
oh
[Music]
you've been talking a lot about this
this boat that you've been on i love my
bond
so so you you love this boat explain to
us the difference between your boat and
field map yeah why is it an issue why is
it that you have an issue with film
dominance maximus aurelia spencer he has
a large 50-foot boat
all right so they wanted a bigger
donation down for my for for me to get
my 45 football i gotta only get i'm i'm
five feet away from
your house you understand
i need y'all more to support playstation
now so just out of curiosity why didn't
you get the 50-foot one man we couldn't
afford it what's wrong with you did you
see our books i just had to buy llc for
the playstation pc
that don't come that's not free the chat
is saying
gaminomics in the chat is saying that
your your original boat is actually the
god of war boat so it's the little
dinghy that's what it was you had
originally a little don't do got a board
dinghy
don't do that to me don't do that to me
please that's why you need to upgrade i
get that
we know
worldwide jim ryan's in god of war we
just don't know listen i'm working very
hard for the people the people the
people have spoken i have come back you
asked me to come on ilp are you giving
me the the opportunity to speak to you
to tell you everything that's going on
with the playstation nation
you guys asked me for pc now you got pc
you're gonna get day and date see me i
former llc
you know what that means i got to get
that money back
baby soft
me and my ginger beer is gonna have my
steam deck on top of my boat with my
feet
while i play god of war ratchet and
clink is coming are you the other day i
dropped a trail of a spider man
i think that was a mistake ps4 version
sir yeah no
it was really pc version i made a
mistake
[Music]
oh that was okay i already dropped the
ps4 version i made a mistake it was pc
version i will correct it later on but
you guys
keep your eyes peeled for what worldwide
worldwide
all right here's the thing i got because
there's a lot of thing and people it
seems that you're so aggressive with it
and now we're finding out more games
we're finding about
big sack boys adventure and you know we
fought it out
who leaked the list
who the hell leaked
okay
look look worldwide gym right i didn't
know why i couldn't leak the list man
i'm sorry you leaked the list yeah yeah
i didn't know you do not
listen
it didn't say nba it didn't say that
there was a picture at the top of the
email they said look at my boat
then it said the information at the
bottom and maybe there's a page too and
that's where the nda is he's a
boy
oh man listen i thought ilp was a friend
of mine
he was a friend of mine listen listen me
and you gotta have uh
your face screw your face screw we found
that attic leaking stuff listen listen i
just came to talk about my grand llc yes
this is all i'm here for
i don't know nothing about no list
listen
i want you guys in january to help me
get this boat please i want everybody to
make sure they go purchase god i don't
care if you got it already go get it
again
go get it again and on the steam deck
you can play it in the new resolution
mode that we have for you
500 people
[Laughter]
last question did you put yoshita up to
that tweet to are you trying to really
promote this
in pockets oh so you call you call gabe
to make that happen because i see you
guys really working hand in hand with
violence cool friends man i told gabe
we're going to go to bermuda he's going
to be on my boat it's a big thing we're
doing we're doing a big thing he hand
out he's not going to go on your boat
he's going on phil's boat though mm-hmm
no no no no hey man hey hey come on
you messy let let you get his balls off
jim
i want people to go outside i'm the
captain
i got you where you are
you guys are not enough for me
i need more the pc guys are ready for me
they've been asking they've been
throwing parties for me i see it on
twitter they ask for jamaican gym mr
world why i'm here for you please
go support it and anybody that thinks
they know exactly what's good for the
playstation brand you don't know because
i know cause i'm the captain now
well we
there you have it there you have it uh
again uh thank you jamaican jim ryan so
one last question for jamaican yes
what will the msrp be for uh god of war
on pc
um
i i was saying it's a 20 game right now
so i think 50 is a good it's a good roll
right
for 500p
that's going to be seven dollars for p
10.
i'm going to make a ton of money off of
this because you guys are going to
follow me over there and you know what
for all you guys to say it will never
happen
pigs will fly first
i see bacon in the sky
oink oink
in your eyes
[Music]
[Laughter]
i'm trying to get wipe out on the pc
yeah and there you have it uh heads high
kill him with the dough
everyone falls in love sometimes with pc
it's absolute dude jamaican jim ryan for
pulling up well requested and we're very
blessed to have these guests obviously
yeah daddy pay you the legend you know
jim ryan taking time out of his schedule
that you know of his busy day to come
see us and we're blessed man we're
blessed to have these type of uh
appearances and you know really the
realm of support really helps this
exclusive you show up
i know you just missed them you just
missed them bro you just missed
ask him what was the resolution for the
spider-man when it come over
i don't know you could we could ask him
on phil's boat next week yeah i guess i
guess we could ask them so look y'all
y'all heard the dudes um addicts off
thoughts real quick is this when i saw
the llc
this is this is what it is yeah this is
what you do when you're making a real
move in that space you're not you had it
you were publishing it under the mobile
like mobile brand before right and you
know
that's not if you're trying to make a
real move in that space that looks real
that looks like you don't care right
and jamaican gym has made it clear that
they care
as a matter of fact a lot of the things
that they talked about i don't know if
you guys remember a couple of weeks ago
capcom announced that moving forward the
pc will be their primary platform and
everything trickles down from the pc
capcom
capcom it's over
and if you think about it if you think
about xbox if you think about all these
other uh like first parties
pc is where the development starts right
before you start before you start you
know going directly onto whatever the
the development dev consoles or whatnot
so the fact of the matter is it's always
made the most sense to start as pc
centric and then trickle it down to
the the the consoles so
the fact that they're kind of making the
statement that
we're pc first and it's very easy to
move everything laterally to the console
space
is telling you that the pc matters more
than now to them than it ever has
creating a space where that is
identified as such not in the way that
it was before is big especially for
playstation like if if xbox did
something like this i wouldn't be as
surprised if nintendo did something that
maybe i'd be surprised yes very
surprised but for sony to do it it's
showing you that all the moves they made
to now are just not one-offs it's not
all we that we're picking and choosing
no yeah the slate is coming later i mean
they literally set the whole slate and
like you said
by the king by the day you start to get
more you know
leaks and obviously the big g-force now
and video leaks had a lot of stuff in
there as well you know the the big sack
boy thing we just saw that but yeah i
agree with you yeah
so i i think i think pc across the board
is going to be the primary platform and
everything trickles down from that
because all the tech now is in line
except for the exception what the [ __ ]
that says man yeah
i mean the ssd they i i actually i was
able to purchase one for 110 dollars off
amazon
you talked about the one that supposedly
would be the deterrent to stop force or
something exactly but you know it's it's
a one terabyte wd black so i'm like okay
so hold up
all of a sudden this is 100 bucks now
what happened
so um yeah
yeah it's they're all just variations of
pcs and uh
it's gonna be easier for them to do so
yeah welcome to the new playstation
cause that's what it is
whoa welcome to the last playstation
you're messing
your thoughts on the uh llc playstation
pc
oh yeah my mic fell off oh you're good
you're good you're good all right all
right it's good mm-hmm all right what
yeah please see places your pc llc your
thoughts on it
ah i expected that
uh they've done nothing but show that
they're putting stuff on pc and you know
the the sooner people accept that the
better
and this is just the next evolution to
have that
um what about this holding on to two
female hanging on to the edge talking
about it it never happened what's up
they need to sign off twitter and just
leave
yeah because they're going to be
disappointed sooner rather than later
because again they all they're already
disappointed so they know later too
they're holding on to oh it's going to
be three years
[Music]
what you know it's interesting because
i'll jump in because um it is
interesting to sense that again i just i
was speaking to kick about this on the
phone
and like
to me
i don't if i feel like a switch got
lifted where they don't care no more
because it's like before they were so
careful and sensitive to like yo you
know oh that was a mistake that demon
souls no no no no that was that you know
what that is though what'd you think
that's um
lord jim ryan got in charge he's in
charge now right and he he's uh he wants
his boat and everything coming to pc
but you know you know what it is too
so the thing is jim now we've always
talked about this how they don't have
any forward-facing faces anymore right
so that engagement with the community
and caring what the community thinks in
that regard it's not happening the way
that it was when you had a shuhei
yoshida and sean layton right and and uh
jack trenton
it's not the same he is so focused on
how do we make money right that the rest
of it is going out the window i agree
in part to a detriment to them in part
right because they don't have that
engagement but the bottom line is
looking real good oh bottle bottom it's
looking better
i think there's a lot of aspects here
that you know it could be a different a
couple different things happening one it
could be that they're concerned for the
future of the brand so they want to make
sure they have as many avenues open as
possible
uh that could be one of them another one
it could be that they have they've hit
the ceiling on what they can make in the
car and he literally said that
yeah and they want to raise that ceiling
but the only way they possibly can raise
the ceiling is is it offer it to more
avenues and more people
yeah they they're not enough so you know
i think that i think it
i think the answer
is in the middle yeah i think it's for a
variety of different i thought it was
not just one or the other i thought it
was interesting that shuhei
was the one that's been tweeting out the
mobile stuff tweeting out
from him in months
we actually thought he was taken
the fact that he did show the steam deck
he is alive and well
he shows that actually the playstation
games look fantastic over here we are
having a great time thank you gabe i'm
alive and well everyone
want to hide me in the basement
listen
we know exactly what this means right
you form an llc this is when you're
serious and you're buckling down yeah
right
that day-to-day thing is going to happen
all right because
they don't buy games
so wherever they can sell games at
they're going to sell it to them and i
know everybody's sitting there like you
know like you said there's no
forward-facing dudes i don't think jim
kiss
yeah him doesn't play video games
exactly right so that's like hiring a
chef that don't know how to cook
right like i don't i don't i don't cook
but you know the business of cooking you
know the business of making restaurants
and making money and making successes
franchises right right so he's not
sympathetically connected to this i feel
you you understand there's a detachment
there which i'm seeing right now
when you can close studios in europe you
can close studios in japan you can do
this and everybody's saying it's a
heartless thing i told you he was a
numbers dude he was a money man
money's in the pc
money's putting your stuff all over the
place so again
we're at this this this point
where i told y'all before we was going
to get to this point and it went a whole
lot faster than i thought
so let me ask you a question king
because hey this is interesting to me um
what do you think differentiates him
from another money man don matrick and
and how that affected xbox negatively
and how jim doesn't seem to be initially
you had the push back for the fanboys
right but
you obviously everything that he's doing
in terms of playstation is to amplify
the name of the brand right the brand so
how are they different how is it that
he's going to help the playstation brand
as opposed to what matrix did on xbox
app
because they're both money men and they
both don't have that emotional
attachment you talked about
jim has a proven track record don has a
track record in a descending
i understand hello zinger hello
don came from one situation where he
tried to sink a ship and he went to
another place in sunken ship you
understand so we know if we leave him in
a place long enough that's exactly
what's going to happen for don
but
man we don't even
if you want if you want to get rid of
sony king just get that dude hired over
there i know i don't want to get rid of
sony that's the whole thing
he's doing exactly he's everything is
going according to plan
everything
100
they saw
the metrics from mlb to show
you can't tell me that's not eye-opening
within itself
this game is on our rivals platform and
it has sold double what we've normally
saw right
i wanna i wanna jump in because this is
interesting and i hate to catch you
because this this is the part i'm
looking at
i'm looking at the
where they're picking and choosing
obviously the is it about calling it
right is it big sack boys adventure am i
calling it correct yeah i think that's
cool i've been calling it now it's sack
boys
sorry exactly why you know i'm feeling
like i'm totally wrong
we just call it that all right so sad
boy right to me
when you hear about that let's be real
like psycho ain't do i don't know if it
did crazy or not to me i feel like
they're doing little tests and my
question the king is do you think it's
gonna be a situation where like
you i know you feel day and day is
coming right but right now i get to feel
like it's an experimental phase as far
as which ones are coming first and
quicker right so do you think it's a
thing where lower sales one way maybe
didn't hit because i don't know what the
sales of of the sagboy joint was but
like do you think the lower sales joints
they're going to be quicker to port
those faster to get the pc money back
fast in relationship to the initial
sales do you think that might be going
on and then eventually go to what you're
talking about
no
no
i feel like whichever games can get uh
ported over quickly yeah all the ones
that go out i think it actually has to
do with
how fast the port can get made okay
right because it it it's telling when
you see
nexus
did not do the port for god war right
right so
it's really
who can move these ports faster and get
them out the door it means they've been
working on god of war for like two years
so whoever
whatever whoever that that company is
yeah i think
you know the rumor is that sack boy is
the next game right yes um
and
i think sackboy makes sense now i think
you're right about the ones that can get
out faster for whatever that reason may
be but i think cyborg makes sense
because of the holiday season right if
you're looking for a family-friendly
game um by all accounts that was a good
game it just and it did better than it
probably would have just because it was
a launch game yeah you get a sack boy
game
i think now when you look at the mascot
quote-unquote for playstation people
look to astro right i think sac boys
sort of fall into the wayside so
a sackboard game that doesn't come out
at a time like launch where you have
more eyes on it isn't going to do well
so
and even so like in the mix with the
miles morales and the demon souls it
probably didn't do super great so my
thinking is that's that's the one to put
out around them now holidays or whatever
they haven't talked about you know they
gotta warn january we don't know if
they're gonna you know shadow drop
something like that like a sac boy right
um
but again i don't know i don't know how
many teams
another thing
yeah
with this llc thing right right
so i this is what's going to happen
either they're going to get more second
parties working on these pc ports as
apart from nexus or they're going to
grow
at the end of the day nexus is probably
going to be their biggest studio when it
comes to because when you need all these
ports you're going to move basically
your entire catalog over
uh
you need people to do that right so
either you're going to continue with the
secondary stuff and nix's work on
certain games or you grow nexus to be
the the powerhouse of porting in all of
gaming so it's going to be interesting
to see where they take this because i
think
it's it it is part of their main
initiative now yeah this is this really
yeah that's yup
this is when you talk about the pillars
of playstation yeah you're talking about
pc bro when you form an llc like you're
making a record label as far as governor
like you you really i got you can't give
me what's like i got you no i'm not
saying that i'm oh i just you just
really done on this topic okay because
it it's at the point now where these
dudes
just don't want to realize what what's
happening right yeah they just accepted
it you know it is the the stage of now
but i guess the point i want to say from
a billion standpoint is that as these
games come out these blockbusters they
are more expensive right they they can
cost the game so to flip back like as
king famously say like you are not
enough right like you got to get this
money back and if there's this whole
group and subset of gamers that are
willing to play these exclusives on pc
you know what i mean and there's money
to be paid back that's gonna get that
cost to get you know more money and then
keep that yeah again
let me ask you a question you just
specifically you yes yes
if
you say and as as business yeah
you take your game you port it over to
the pc
let's say it doesn't do the numbers you
think it's supposed to do right
on pc let's say you said to yourself um
i expect at least four million sales
right okay
from from from big sac board that's a
big size you're looking at four million
so you're saying four million sales oh
let's say two million whatever whatever
whatever number internal number you put
inside your head
it don't make those sales do you look to
other avenues to make that money up
because
i know people keep saying that sony had
no choice with mlb the show right
but at what point in time do you look at
the competitor that actually showed you
they can sell your game because there's
already a gaming ecosystem that's there
right right right
i mean
to me this is where he goes south yeah
he's going south i know where he's going
with this all right he's going his
console back yeah he going
i mean i'm still not there yet but i
know where you're going like to me
it's going to be a situation where they
like okay
from
listen you're gonna get the boat money
by first
putting it over the pc right the
question to me is when i think right now
they go okay
let's kill it let's get like as soft
says the zeitgeist get all the accolades
of the of the season of the promotion he
advertised with a big exclusive right
then as that
whittles down then it's like okay boom
the thing that i'm very curious with is
when something like you said king
doesn't hit initially
right
does that in turn
intensify the port
being pushed out quicker that that's
what i'm curious about with them stay in
that zeitgeist moment right stay in that
window where everybody's talking about
said game does uh horizon forbidden west
become that test bed
it'll be interesting it'll be
interesting to see if they like i said
if they do the day and date what is the
first one and and why like i'm just
because to me it feels like they're
still
figuring out data they're getting data
wow we made money here well this is
really good look what we did horizon you
know what i'm saying you know what it
could be what it could be
the show 2021 though 2022
could be the show um
it's already on other platforms they
haven't done the pc version i think
right i think could be the show could be
what's that better i think what's going
to determine how quick games come to
game day and day is going to determine
how many games underperformed yes
because i feel like the more they put
games on pc because if they underperform
i feel like it's going to come quicker
and because i think they might see a
bigger return and the quicker and the
sooner they keep releasing games on pc
and seeing a bigger and bigger return
because we know how the gaming industry
it's about what's hot right now not
necessarily what's hot in six months
just because something is being sold now
doesn't mean that they're gonna buy it
in six months we've seen uh the scenario
right now where you know just because
you see go that's that's going away for
it on sale how often do we actually pick
that game up on sale because at that
point it's not hot it's yes yeah yeah
yeah it's it's not the game everyone's
playing i think you're gonna see a lot
of that on playstation games going to pc
sure there's going to be a lot of people
that pick up god of war but that
probably would have been quadruple the
amount of people if god of war ragnarok
or god of war 2018 came out day and day
on game on everything well yeah be like
on game pass what was that on game pass
what was that
it came out day i almost leaked
something else
about danny day on on play on pc because
then you're gonna see the you know it's
i think a lot of pc people are gonna
pick this up but i think there's a lot
of pc people that won't pick it up
because it's just like look i already
know the ending i've already seen plenty
of cut scenes the game's like four years
old right i think there is going to be
that that set of people that's like but
if you give that to me on day and day
you have a better chance of getting my
cell because everyone's gonna be right
because
a lot of the argument conversation a lot
of the argument now is that okay you
have the people on pc who never were
ever gonna get a playstation and now are
experiencing for the first time right
then you have the people there saying
okay i'm going to double dip and get it
on on pc as well because i want all that
fidelity i have a great pc i want that
fidelity right so i still don't you if
you put those numbers together i still
don't think they compare to
day and gate when that game first comes
out 2018 is getting tens across the
board you see corey barlow crying online
like you see all of that
i i don't think the numbers you're
getting now even with those two caveats
would compare to everybody to everybody
at the same time so you're saying yeah
yeah yeah you're saying that if it okay
get out yeah that game could be 30
right now
whenever it comes out and they still
won't sell as many as it was if this
game came out so basically you're saying
the pc community will be more inclined
to pick it up
in the middle of that i mean at the
beginning of that cycle so they can be
on point with the same thing yeah
absolutely
perfect example guardians of the galaxy
not many people is messing with this
let's say that this game didn't come out
on pcs coming out in six months uh
people who didn't have a whole lot of
faith in guardians of the galaxy right
but
the amount of height the amount of talk
the galaxy's getting right now it is
spreading like wild wildfire so i was at
a party and cognito and his incognito
picked it up yeah so it's just like
literally i'm in a party yeah sinister
picked it up game show
that's happening just on in one xbox
live party imagine if that was in pc2
that's a good point right now in 2018
you didn't have that it's like that
whole pc tree is cut off and maybe they
just need to see the data
of a day and date release to see oh my
lord like king and say look what this is
doing for the pc numbers to say yo
we gotta yeah i see where you're going
another thing i think attic alluded to
this too is just the fact that the type
of games that sony that sony makes right
are those games that you know
you're gonna you're gonna get the last
of us spoiled for you yeah you're right
you're right yeah you're right
so it's less exciting if you get that
game on pc however many yeah because the
bang
it's been exposed people know what
happened
you've missed yeah i see you good point
good point and that's their format their
format is the the the just one right the
narrative narrative experience with an
ending now i see what you're going
that's where you're going look we killed
this we already know what it is let's
get this last joint and out of here and
um so if you got that patrol you want to
wait until the last one and then do
everything um let's do everything
together at the end at the end all right
cool attic man you're up you got a good
one man xbox game studios man what's
talk to me what's going on you know
we
when microsoft bought all those studios
and they bought bethesda and we're
seeing some stuff with bethesda already
one of the biggest questions people as
like are they going to deliver the type
of games are they going to deliver the
content the quality and i think this
year we've seen that i mean it's before
this year i mean i'm pretty sure
waistline three came out last year
correct
and you know waistline three the outer
worlds we saw with them we saw all their
expansions we're seeing it with
psychonauts 2 we're seeing it with age
of empire which
they built that studio we're seeing it
with
forza horizon we're seeing it with halo
infinite like
this is like half
their studio is half caught right like
majority of their studios haven't even
delivered anything yet correct and these
are the games that haven't even been
funded by microsoft these are the games
that microsoft came in at the ass end of
the development cycle helped them push
it out the door
just to get that out there and i'm
telling like i think that you're going
to see a lot of these studios
they're going to deliver the same
content and better quality going out
throughout the years people haven't seen
ninja theory yet we haven't seen
compulsion we haven't seen uh undead
labs in the next game like
it the proof is in the pudding waistline
three eight plus 85 plus on metacritic
um
psychonauts 85 plus on metacritic i
think age of empires like 84 85
like we're seeing
right in front of us the quality of
games that these studios can make out of
worlds like 88 89 on metacritic like i
have a feeling that people aren't ready
for when microsoft's engine is popping
out games and i think the biggest game
that's going to really test this theory
and test what they're doing is star
field next year yeah that'll be a big
that'll be a big one no it's a good
point it's a lot it's a lot of you know
they've got every internally people like
yo there's there's a little streak going
on right there's a of quality games
coming out from but what do you feel
about xbox game studio soft like just
moving forward and obviously setting up
for this year and stuff
i mean i think i talked about it a
little bit last week i was just like you
know
we've we've basically gotten the big mac
lost fries and scope this year because
we we've got high busters at the end of
of the year last year we're getting
fours the next week and we're getting
halo after that
um
and i said that that that that fast food
meal is tasting pretty damn good
there's a level of polish on these games
that you know uh
we've kind of
been missing from from from xbox game
studios and been critical of them
because of that um and i think alex 100
right i think matt booty alluded to it
in his interview as well with uh kind of
funny when he was like i'm most excited
for their next you know all of these
studios next games the ones that we came
in on the back end and still had you
know had the games on game pass but they
were almost
like at the end of the day psychonauts
had no boss battles really they put a
lot of that content back in the game
because microsoft gave them the time
that they needed the time and the money
to do it and and make the game that they
wanted to make without cutting corners
and i think you know we all this talk
about consolidation in the gaming
industry or whatever
i think when it comes to a lot of these
smaller developers that have to fight
tooth and nail for every single game
that they make and they're literally
bouncing on eggshells every single time
they make a game
um that security is going to allow
creativity to to blossom and and just
not you don't have to worry about where
your next check is coming from and i
think it does a lot
especially on the microsoft side where
we we for a long time we've been
critical of their ability to sort of put
out quality games and not have all these
issues behind the scenes and whatnot and
that stuff still happens and i just
think that there's a big focus on it on
the microsoft side because again they
haven't had the end results that sony
has had in terms of you know metacritic
scores and and and and how these games
are received but i think moving forward
and i think even i know attic mentioned
starfield i think we're seeing it
already i think this for if i guarantee
you there are going to be plenty of
people who say when the reviews come out
for the horizon 5
there's going to be a few reviews that
say the greatest grayson game ever i
guarantee i guarantee you it's going to
be those reasons
when halo comes
uh everything that i've seen so far
after craig
has given me so much hope for that game
and like you said starfield next year to
me is bethesda game studios opportunity
to come back for anybody that says hey
fallout 4 was saying me uh
whatchamacallit uh the whatever the
mm476 not great whatever
this is their opportunity like okay
this is a bethesda's game studios game
through and through
it is as polished as you've ever seen
this game and it is as as an immersive
and deeper world as you've ever had from
a desert game studios and it's it's
because of being able to be with that
umbrella of microsoft because if you
look at all their other games right the
games that did well for bethesda leading
up to this the wolfensteins the dooms
there were smaller games in scope than a
bethesda rpg right
they needed and if you started to look
at before the acquisition they were
starting to lean into more pop culture
properties right safer properties we
would not be getting the the death loops
and the dishonors of the world if they
did not have that sort of backing
because it was not safe to do that
now they're safe to create what they
want to create right
yo
they to me honestly bro honestly like i
you know i'm i'm super critical of them
but but i love them and i think they're
finally on track to really blow us away
with damn near everything they drop
right like
if you look at how many swings they've
if they've taken right in the past year
or so they're not missing much yeah the
average is pretty damn high
um and i don't think that stops with
forza horizon or halo i i think we're in
for a great great generation with them
let me let me address some side note i
see the chat in here
and it's the person in here that's a
little while now listen
we can agree to disagree on opinions and
all that but when you ask someone and
it's in a personal attack we're gonna
get you out of here i don't care what
went on in some other chat stop
personalizing the tax if you can't if
the if the person is bothering you so
much in the chat just block that person
and listen to the podcast but going back
and forth attacking other people i'm
telling people y'all continue to do that
i will get you out of here i'm not
playing them games so we'll take that to
some other podcast we're not doing that
here
people can we're not concerned with
who's right or wrong
all that and
so make up your mind person or persons
if you want to be here we're not doing
it i don't continue i don't particularly
care what happened in another chat
that's not yeah that's not it's not if
you got issues with that other
individual you could take out one of
them in another form uh you don't need
to take that up yeah don't be doing that
ahead so anyway continue y'all okay
i know they're gonna make good games i
don't know
like you got to let them cook
everybody wants to oh what's what are
they doing what's going on what are we
going to see how how's everything gonna
be
we got forza that's getting ready to
drop in a minute then right after that
we got our halo let's get ray drop
they are listen
when they drop the um
the playing game um
flight simulator yeah flight simulator i
was about to call the pilot wings
when they dropped flight simulator
people didn't think that was going to be
able to be done right and i'm i'm listen
i'm the biggest fraud i'm not even going
to say hello i told you
i was flying over the projects to see
where i was born
and that's it
after that i went i went to egypt and um
i understood
okay and i'll be back when they do the
f1 fighter jets and we can get i think
i'll actually play something like that
probably a little bit longer not much
but the f1 fighter jets
but hog is frozen yeah
they try to get us out of here
i see it
yeah well yeah yeah i'm frozen too yeah
all right
listen
they they the psychonauts i love the
stuff but like attic was saying these
are stuff that was on the tail and that
they came in and they tidied up they
buttoned up and they put it out and and
we got them and then we are well
received games right so
excuse me
sky's the limit for the next games that
actually come out that was made under
the banner specifically from this
partnership going forward
my biggest thing is
who's the next acquisitions because it
seems like these guys got to get out of
this holiday season that is a big
holiday season 20 years they really have
to put this down the market and stuff is
really going really well
they have two huge games that they're
dropping and then you know they got the
multiplayer and stuff coming later
i want to know
who's the acquisitions that they're not
talking about now right and we already
know that they're publishers
right so it's big stuff so when when
somebody can sit there and say hey
we are aren't we
at 30 million
that's a high raiser why is we you
understand so
i want i want to see things happen i
want to see who else did they acquire
because we know that game pass cannot
just you know live off the big mac fries
and shake correct that can't be the
thing so there has to be a diversified
portfolio going forward that's what
we're looking forward to and the
hopefulness is the fact that we know
it's no longer going to be big mac fries
and shakes
you know you're going to get a steak
you're going to get some lobster you're
going to get some calamari you're going
to get some different things that's
going along in every month you know so
when adam gets the chance to play his a
vow and his vow comes in at a 98
metacritic
[Music]
yeah you have people going crazy but i
also said i also say playstation on pc
and dudes thought i was crazy anyway
so you maybe you might review it maybe
you give it that 98 right all right so
those games are coming and the future is
bright and i told people before the
future is bright with xbox and dudes was
clowning me look at you now
yeah no i mean at the end of the day
yeah i mean it is bright i mean there's
a lot of what it was cool i love the
diversity and to me it's this year i
think
this is the first holiday in a while
where it's just like wow they got a lot
for this holiday not even nintendo or
sony
really can match for the first time like
they've got the holiday for themselves
to me it started from the back for blood
now you got the age of vampires you know
that force is going to come in pretty
high it's pretty you know we know
playgrounds reputation yeah they do
and um yeah you know it's far halo
listen good or bad halo moves the needle
when halo drops it's a monster and for
all intents and purposes we know the
multiplayer super solid super strong you
know i mean the campaign now looking
like what it is so yeah they got the
holly got the chance to really dominate
the news cycle and then on top of that
last thing that 20th anniversary that's
a lot of nostalgia a lot of history you
know they're going to show out with that
we're expecting big things from that and
um yeah they got they got pretty much
the the fall unlock if they execute so
it'll be interesting
it's it's crazy to think about how
different things might feel and look
if they had dropped that halo half
cocked last year yes
yes it's a good point microsoft did that
yes and i'm glad they didn't but look
that's all i got no let's get these
super chassis in the pool get up out of
here
all righty hold on make sure i got this
last one
yes okay okay i got that one so let me
roll back a little bit
i could do the pole if you want what's
up yeah go ahead do that all right cool
so new ilp pole with sony's recent
formation of the playstation pc llc
brand
do you think the company's recent
aggressiveness with pc ports is
devaluing the playstation brand
the choices are a yes less playstation
console sold under this bottle games are
devalued if pc ports are in proximity
day and day of ps5 releases
choice b no the model is this model is
pro ip and financially helps the brand
sell more better long term games for
sony or c
i don't care we told y'all worldwide gym
is not for play play those are the five
please rock it when it goes out it'll be
up on the iron podcast twitter account
again shout out to the legendary danny
penguin og the power father that pulled
up gave us tremendous game tremendous
history tremendous stories man it is man
what og we gotta talk to him forever and
solve let's get these super chats man
get the people out of here and get
addicts and food before you pass out and
we got josh mccarthy five dollars which
had lord attic wanting uh yeah the dax
thing never mind raiden blade two dollar
super chat uh two pounds super chat was
neo not the weapon for agent smith
uh then we got fat boy horror five
pounds super chat nix's heart mr
worldwide jim ryan is very excited to
see him on the panel today oh
we got har gee chaney two dollar super
chat so
wolverine day and date on pc
that would be the smart move
then we got flame five dollars we chat
jim
what was that trailer for miles morales
were you telling people on ps4 to buy it
or it goes to pc
are you threatening yourself they don't
buy them to play you stupid
are you threatening your fans now
we'll need to get our pr person to ask
jim right now yes yes um
then we got scrub nurse i remember for
for 17 months
you guys are messy as hell i love it
keep up the great work shout out to the
awesome panel the chat hit that like
button don't don't die
we got smitty smith five dollars let me
check worldwide gym call me now for free
for a free bomber clapton
yo
i just it's schmidty i hope you know
what that word yes please
and he made it scripture as well oh my
god
bernard miller remember for seven months
shout out lord for a great interview and
the most entertaining show going how
long to the revolt for 50 to 60 games on
pc and 70 on playstation oh that's going
to be a conversation for sure
um
they'll take it
rather blade 2 power super chat 30 gig
gap between series and ps5 card what
cracking
i don't know
yeah
then we got raiden blade two pounds so
we chat jim will put games on xbox mlb
makes sense
then we got auburn king five pound super
chat i think sony can't afford to care
they keep saying development is getting
more expensive and they're chasing more
sales xbox is competing now too exactly
the money is the bottom line is the
bottom line right now
rate and blade two pound super chat ps
games will sell on xbox sony don't need
to waste r d
they don't that's true
har geek cheney five dollar super chat
wait aren't you going to talk about the
state of play that's not what you're
saying
yeah we kind of did the stream on it so
i i forgot
yeah
was it you know was it was it for me it
wasn't for me let's just say that yeah
it was it was very important that was
for me it's actually really for me
then we got doobie five dollar super
chat if and when sony games go to day
and date what will be the launch price
fifty dollar sixty dollars we know they
can't do seventy on pc we won't buy um
forty to fifty yeah
when jim tell you to buy
that that that to me is going to be
interesting when because
you're saying seven dollars on this
console right you know
it's gonna be 70 over there yeah
yeah you didn't know you get out i mean
it might it might it might be one of
those where there's so much pushback
back but i don't know shout out to the
500 people we have in here man go ahead
hit that like button that like button
and i was last one super chicken i got a
merch i gotta read off
that was it all right cool again
anonymous he got that stainless tumbler
20 ounces shout out to the iron lords
the best the best not an xbox xbox
podcast great interview today
horizon and halo could get here fast
enough salute to anonymous don't forget
put your name again tremendous show
salute to the legendary daily pin yeah
outstanding history the pod father hall
of famer legend you already know attic
where can i find people find you what do
you have going on sir
you can find me on twitter lord addict
iop you can find me on the iop twitch
channel going to probably be streaming
um
uh i'm gonna be streaming uh probably
forza when ever i think it's thursday so
sometime thursday i'll be streaming that
don't expect a whole lot on that
uh i i i love racing games and i think
the forza franchise has always been the
exception because no i don't love racing
games but the forza games have always
been the uh uh the exception because
it's nice to like drive around in cars i
don't even know the names too but you
know uh it's nice there but i will be
streaming um writer's republic i i know
for a fact because i'm really enjoying
that and uh me and kit smooth are going
to play this i'm probably going to troll
him for a couple of minutes uh but i
definitely appreciate it for coming
through here man we we will be uh
starting uh you know the process i do
know that we owe you a r r podcast yes
so we'll we'll get that took care of
eventually i do want to point out that
we'll probably have that r r podcast
launched publicly
uh january the second because we will
not have a podcast then yeah correct we
gotta
take your time for the new year
yeah my birthday yeah yeah
[Laughter]
no doubt no doubt solve where can the
five people find you and also some super
chat
no doubt you can find well in a few
moments i'm going to be recording the
week's uh lord's minute with lady april
so i'll be doing that in a few moments
and i'll be going to work so you'll be
finding me
not anywhere
lord king
thank you for uh pulling up and making
the connections
happen for us for these big interviews
that you've been securing uh where can
five people find you what you got going
on sir knocks on the door i gotta let
them in post
you find me on uh legion of doom fridays
at 9 00 p.m
uh we are also on the road to uh 15k yes
uh we're working out the kinks but um
we're we're going to be giving away
consoles
all right so um we're working out the
kinks in that we don't have anything to
really announce at this moment but the
road to 15k leads straight to a console
we're gonna figure out which console
that we're gonna get y'all we uh did a
great job with getting uh you guys a
playstation uh five and xbox series x um
and we want to give back so
uh we're uh pushing that forward um we
see the merch that you guys are uh
picking up yeah uh we're merged coming
yeah new merch alert is on the way
mm-hmm uh
this week gonna be some of y'all yeah yo
yo
your best stuff you know you're gonna
really like this stuff when it goes up
um thank you for all the support guys i
really appreciate everybody that's
inside this chat man
that's crazy um it's fantastic as you
can see uh camera upgrade mic upgrade uh
everything that we get from you guys we
put it right back into the podcast and
we have fantastic guests that i really
i'm so happy that uh danny was on today
so i can get a chance to know about his
story and his journey yeah and the fact
that to find out that um he he gives
back in such a wholehearted way and we
have a lot of people in our community
that's like that so to actually come
across a brother who actually is
influential in a lot of areas is
fantastic you know and
you know uh paris gave it up and i see
why i see why yeah i see why he he's
he's affected so many people yes um
solve get those super chats we roll out
but we got raiden blade two pounds super
chat cod size 30 gigs more on ps5 so
kraken versus velocity
cracking
then we got don otaku twenty dollars
which there's something to be excited
about with xbox unlike the others
because they're such an unknown in many
ways they haven't reached their full
potential from their studios to tech
like velocity architecture that hasn't
hit it's true there's still a lot of
stuff on the on the console side that
you know we still haven't seen
you know the ai stuff with the uh with
the resolution super resolution and
stuff like that so that all that stuff
is by the end of the generation
these machines are going to be doing
things that you were not expecting them
to be able to do that's for sure no no
that's everything
yeah we're good no doubt look man
tremendous show appreciate your support
mad love more fun things as king said as
addict said more things popping we
really appreciate y'all and uh tune in
next week
you already know the vines everybody
enjoy your sunday we out peace
so
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
you